You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye. and health conditions at early stages.
你知道，你的眼睛承受了很多压力。每天阅读、在昏暗光线下看东西、长时间盯着屏幕——这种情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光，甚至夜间驾驶都会导致视疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛负担很重。因此，通过定期的眼科检查来呵护它们并监测其健康状况非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行眼科检查，只需 99 美元起，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段发现眼部健康问题。
To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.ca. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. Let's top groceries, specifically your groceries with Instacart. You want your groceries just the way you like them, right? Well, the Instacart app lets you do just that. They have a new preference picker that lets you pick how ripe or unripe you
要查找您附近的门店并预约 99 美元起的 OCT 扫描眼科检查，请访问 specksavers.ca。眼科检查由独立验光师提供。价格可能因地点而异。现在来聊聊杂货，特别是用 Instacart 购买杂货。你希望你的杂货买回来正合你意，对吧？嗯，Instacart 应用程序就能让你做到这一点。他们有一个新的偏好选择器，让你能挑选你想要的香蕉成熟度。
want your bananas. Shoppers can see your preferences up front, helping guide their choices. Instacart, get groceries just how you like. Welcome to your second drink of Job Fair. We had a lot to say in this episode about washing our hands, blisters, and golf courses. Such a weird list. We also got tons of mail about the deleted cold open that I had shared about for this episode. It's where Michael loses all of the stuff in the toilet. Yep. It was in deleted scenes, and I wasn't able to play it, but it's been added back to the Peacock Superfan version. It starts with Michael screaming from the bathroom, and Dwight rushes off to help him, and then they both walk into the bullpen,
购物者可以提前看到你的偏好，从而引导他们的选择。Instacart，买到你心仪的杂货。欢迎来到《招聘会》这一集的第二杯。在这一集中，我们聊了很多关于洗手、水泡和高尔夫球场的话题。真是个奇怪的清单。我们还收到了大量关于我之前分享的这一集被删减的冷开场的邮件。那是迈克尔把所有东西都掉进马桶里的情节。没错。它在删减片段里，我没能播放它，但它已经被加回了 Peacock 的超级粉丝版本中。它以迈克尔在洗手间尖叫开始，德怀特冲过去帮他，然后他们俩走进办公区，
and Dwight is carrying a bunch of stuff in a paper towel. Let's hear it. No. I do not want to talk about it. Unbelievable. That, okay. What happened, Michael? Oh, wouldn't you like to know what happened in the bathroom by myself? Purvy. Suffice to say, I finished my business. I was just checking to make sure everything was fine. And my cell phone fell out and on, not in, but like on the rim. And then... It fell in. Just let me tell the story. Okay, Jim, I knocked it with my knee, and then it fell in. And then I leaned over and looked, and my glue tooth fell out of my ear. And that fell in. And then I got flustered and everything started falling in. My wallet fell in, my tip calculator, my candy corn, my white straight.
德怀特用纸巾包着一堆东西。我们来听听。不。我不想谈论它。难以置信。好吧，迈克尔，发生了什么？哦，你难道不想知道我在洗手间里一个人发生了什么吗？变态。简单来说，我办完了事。我只是检查一下确保一切正常。然后我的手机掉了出来，掉在——不是掉进，而是掉在边缘上。然后……它掉进去了。让我把话说完。好吧，吉姆，我用膝盖碰了一下，然后它就掉进去了。接着我俯身去看，我的蓝牙耳机从耳朵里掉了出来。也掉进去了。然后我慌了，所有东西都开始掉进去。我的钱包掉进去了，我的小费计算器，我的玉米糖，我的美白牙贴。
all fell in to the toilet. And your keys fell in? I threw the keys in out of anger. Right. This cannot happen again. That's what you said last time. I know I did. Phyllis, this isn't funny.
全都掉进了马桶里。那你的钥匙也掉进去了？我因为生气把钥匙扔进去了。对。这种情况不能再发生了。你上次也是这么说的。我知道我说了。菲利斯，这并不好笑。
This is not funny. Well, technically it is toilet humor, which you claim to enjoy. It is not toilet humor. It is toilet tragedy. Hey. Hey. You know what? This is the best thing that ever happened to me. This is all scene, please, you guys, it's so worth a watch. It's so funny.
这并不好笑。嗯，严格来说这是厕所幽默，你声称你很喜欢这种幽默。这不是厕所幽默。这是厕所悲剧。嘿。嘿。你知道吗？这是我经历过的最棒的事情。这全是场景，拜托，你们一定要看，太搞笑了。
I can't believe that this was cut. I would have cut anything out of the episode. I mean, it's a great episode, but like they, I feel like more should have been done to keep this cold open. I say it in our breakdown, but I remember from the table read laughing so hard when he says he threw his keys in out of anger. I know. Also, how much shit does he keep in his pocket? So much. How did the tip calculator get involved? I know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. So after this, there is a scene where Michael comes out of his office and he is holding a new invention. This is the invention that is going to save you from having your stuff fall in the toilet.
我不敢相信这段被剪掉了。我宁愿把这一集里的任何其他东西剪掉。我的意思是，这是一集很棒的剧集，但我感觉应该做更多努力来保留这个冷开场。我在我们的解析里说过，但我记得在剧本朗读时，当他说他因为生气把钥匙扔进去时，我笑得太厉害了。我知道。还有，他口袋里到底装了多少破烂？太多了。小费计算器是怎么卷进去的？我知道。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。所以在这之后，有一个场景是迈克尔从办公室出来，手里拿着一项新发明。这就是那个能拯救你，防止你的东西掉进马桶里的发明。
Right. And you described it from the script when we first broke down the episode. But, oh, my gosh, seeing the footage again, oh, my. Michael is showing it off. He's standing at reception. So I'm in this two shot with him. And he's holding up his invention. And I just remember the first time I saw it, I immediately started laughing.
对。当我们第一次解析这一集时，你根据剧本描述了它。但是，天哪，再次看到这段录像，哦，我的天。迈克尔在炫耀它。他站在接待处。我和他有一个双人镜头。他举着他的发明。我只记得第一次看到它时，我立刻就开始笑了。
This is something that Phil Shea had to make. And I had not seen it yet. And it broke me. Well, it's just so ridiculous. It's like the head of a tennis racket, but then the handle's been chopped off. But then it's like a dishwashing brush attached. But then it has a chain. Yeah, you know, the thing you wash your dishes with, the brush?
这是菲尔·谢必须制作的东西。我当时还没见过它。它彻底击垮了我。嗯，它太荒谬了。它就像一个网球拍的拍头，但把手被砍掉了。然后上面还连着一个洗碗刷。但它还有一条链子。是的，你知道那种你用来洗碗的刷子吗？
Like, imagine that dangling from the, top of a tennis racket by a chain. So I guess the... So you put the racket over the toilet bowl. Right. And you have to do your business through the racket threads. Yes. And then you use the brush because, as Michael says, it's self-cleaning. Yes. I mean, it's you cleaning. It's you cleaning. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. But you clearly can only go number one. Uh, I mean, I would think. But it's just, it's so absurd. But it's also just, but it's also just, one of the funniest things. I'm so glad it's in the super van. Same. Okay, well, we also got this letter from Sandra P. Sandra says, whenever I watch job fair, I find it interesting that the series starts with
就像，想象一下它用链子挂在网球拍的顶部。所以我猜……所以你把球拍放在马桶圈上。对。然后你必须透过球拍的网格来办你的事。是的。然后你用那个刷子，因为正如迈克尔所说，它是自清洁的。是的。我的意思是，是你自己在清洁。是你自己在清洁。嗯哼。嗯哼。但你显然只能去“小号”。呃，我的意思是，我想是这样。但这太荒谬了。但它也只是，但它也只是，最有趣的事情之一。我很高兴它在超级粉丝版里。我也是。好吧，我们还收到了桑德拉·P 的这封信。桑德拉说，每当我观看《招聘会》时，我都觉得很有趣，因为该系列开始于
downsizing and closing branches and firing people, and now they are actively recruiting people at a job fair. Michael should have hired Devin back. I loved this letter because I didn't even put that together. Yes, the whole series of the office of season like one through three is just about downsizing. Are we going to lose our job? Stamford closes. Yes. We're constantly worried about losing our jobs, but now we're at a job fair. Yeah, now we're recruiting people to work for us that we can't afford to hire. So true. So, you know, in this episode when Pam has to go find a second sheet of paper, Do you remember that whole thing? Like Michael is like, bring one piece of paper.
裁员、关闭分公司和解雇员工，而现在他们却在招聘会上积极招人。迈克尔本该把德文雇回来的。我喜欢这封信，因为我甚至没把这些联系起来。是的，整个《办公室》第一到第三季系列就是关于裁员的。我们会丢掉工作吗？斯坦福分公司关闭了。是的。我们一直担心丢掉工作，但现在我们在招聘会上。是的，现在我们在招人来为我们工作，而我们根本雇不起他们。太真实了。所以，你知道在这一集中，当帕姆不得不去寻找第二张纸时，你还记得那整件事吗？就像迈克尔说，带一张纸来。
Yeah. And then somebody signs their name on it, so she has to go find another piece of paper. Well, she goes to her old art room, and along the way, she sees a photo of Roy in the trophy case in the hallway. He's in, like, his football gear, and it says he was all city team, first place, 1995. Pam stops, and she looks at it, and she says, Roy, nine years of my life. Then she goes into the art room and she's kind of looking to see, oh my gosh, I wonder if it's still up on display. Yeah, Pam's art. Some art piece that she was obviously proud of, and it's not.
是的。然后有人在上面签了名，所以她不得不去再找一张纸。嗯，她去了她以前的艺术室，在路上，她看到了走廊奖杯柜里罗伊的照片。他穿着橄榄球装备，上面写着他是 1995 年全城队成员。帕姆停下来，看着它，她说，罗伊，我生命中的九年。然后她走进艺术室，她有点想看看，哦天哪，不知道它是否还在展出。是的，帕姆的艺术作品。她显然引以为傲的某件艺术品，但它不在那儿。
Well, I love this observation we got from Patrick R. in Boise, Idaho, who said, I always thought it was an extra dig at Pam that Roy's photo was still displayed, but her art was gone. They left up his accomplishment, but not hers. It's so weird. I never put that together. I never put together that, like, it was like this added dig. Yeah. And I liked that.
嗯，我喜欢我们从爱达荷州博伊西的帕特里克·R 那里得到的这个观察，他说，我一直认为罗伊的照片还在展出而她的艺术作品却不见了，这对帕姆来说是一种额外的挖苦。他们留下了他的成就，却没有留下她的。太奇怪了。我从来没把这些联系起来。我从来没想过，这就像是一种额外的挖苦。是的。我喜欢这一点。
I'm sure that was intentional by the writers. Oh, yeah. Yeah. It's also sort of that, and I don't know if you guys had experienced this in any of your schools growing up. But I do remember our football team had the biggest budget in our arts and theater did not. Sure. So a little bit that, of course, of course those trophies are still around. Yes.
我相信这是编剧有意为之的。哦，是的。是的。这也算是那种情况，我不知道你们在成长过程中在学校里是否经历过。但我确实记得我们的橄榄球队拥有最大的预算，而我们的艺术和戏剧部门却没有。当然。所以有点那种感觉，当然，当然那些奖杯还在那里。是的。
And also, like, you don't get trophies. necessary. There's no trophy case for the artists in the school. The debaters, maybe the athletes. Best one I play. Maybe there's a plaque somewhere back in the green room. Or speech. Yeah. You know. Well, finally we got this letter from Jennifer M. who said, you didn't talk about Charlie McDermott playing the cool high school guy on the podcast. Did he act in the job fair while he was on the middle? Well, first off, my apologies for not giving Charlie McDermott a proper guest star breakdown. I'm going to do it now. Great. Charlie broke onto the acting scene with his role in Frozen River, for which he was nominated for an independent film award. He went on to star in the middle. He did 215 episodes over nine years. He even directed an episode. And yes, he must have been doing the middle at this time. Charlie is now primarily a musician. And when I did my guest star breakdown for Trevor Einhorn in this episode, I mentioned that Trevor was a Scorpio. Angela, you asked me if I was going to mention the Astero. signs of our future guest stars. I have not. But just since it's all in this episode, I thought I would add that Charlie McDermott is an hei's. Well, that's fantastic. Well, you guys,
而且，你也不会得到奖杯。没必要。学校里没有给艺术家准备的奖杯柜。辩论队，也许运动员有。我参加的最好的一个。也许在后台休息室里有块牌子。或者演讲。是的。你知道。好吧，最后我们收到了詹妮弗·M 的这封信，她说，你们在播客里没谈到查理·麦克德莫特扮演那个酷高中生的事。他在出演《中间人》时在《招聘会》里演戏了吗？嗯，首先，对于没给查理·麦克德莫特一个正式的客串嘉宾解析，我表示歉意。我现在就来做。太棒了。查理凭借在《冰冻之河》中的角色闯入了演艺圈，并因此获得了独立电影奖提名。他后来主演了《中间人》。他在九年里拍了 215 集。他甚至执导了一集。是的，他当时一定是在拍《中间人》。查理现在主要是一名音乐家。当我在这一集中为特雷弗·艾因霍恩做客串嘉宾解析时，我提到特雷弗是天蝎座。安吉拉，你问我是否会提到我们未来客串嘉宾的星座。我没有。但既然这一集里都有，我想我应该补充一下，查理·麦克德莫特是白羊座。嗯，那太棒了。好吧，你们大家，
that's all we got. Please enjoy your second drink of Job Fair. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you we're the office ladies. Hi lady and everyone. Hi everyone out there. I'm so happy you're here listening. Jenna and I someday we're going to come out there and take it on the road and meet you.
这就是我们所有的内容了。请享受你们的《招聘会》第二杯。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。嗨，女士们，大家好。嗨，外面的每个人。我很高兴你们在这里收听。珍娜和我，总有一天我们会走出去，去巡回演出，去见你们。
Whoa. That's news to me. I guess we're doing it though because if Angela gets an idea, it's going to happen. I think we got to do one in Scranton, Jenna. Oh, well, that's a given. We got to go to Scranton. We got to do an office ladies from Scranton. All right. It's been said. Now it must be done.
哇。这对我来说是新闻。我想我们得这么做，因为如果安吉拉有了主意，它就会发生。我觉得我们得在斯克兰顿做一场，珍娜。哦，嗯，那是肯定的。我们必须去斯克兰顿。我们必须在斯克兰顿做一场《办公室女士》。好吧。话已出口。现在必须完成。
Lady, tell them what we're talking about today. Today is season four, episode 17, job fair. This was written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepnitzky, writers of dinner party. And directed by Tucker Gates. Would you like a summary? I can't wait for your summaries. Like Wednesday night, you know, because we record on Thursday, I go to bed and I'm like, ooh, what is Jenna's summary going to be?
女士，告诉他们我们今天在聊什么。今天是第四季第 17 集，《招聘会》。这是由《晚宴》的编剧李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编写的。由塔克·盖茨执导。你想要一个总结吗？我等不及你的总结了。就像周三晚上，你知道，因为我们在周四录制，我上床睡觉时会想，噢，珍娜的总结会是什么样呢？
I know you do. I know. you try to text me and get me to tell you my summary is ahead of time and I say you're just going to have to wait for it. Yeah, you want to surprise me. I go to bed thinking about it. I wake up thinking about it. Well, here it is, wait no longer. Okay. Michael, Pam, Oscar and Daryl attend a job fair at Pam's alma mater, Valley View High School in search of the quote, best and brightest potential summer interns. Jim is on probation at Dunder Mifflin. You know, he got his warning from Ryan. So he is going to attempt to redeem himself by working a potential client over golf with the help of Andy and Kevin.
我知道你会这样。我知道。你试着给我发短信，想让我提前告诉你我的总结，而我说你只能等着听。是的，你想给我惊喜。我睡觉时在想它。我醒来时也在想它。好吧，它来了，不用再等了。好的。迈克尔、帕姆、奥斯卡和达里尔参加了帕姆的母校——山景高中的招聘会，寻找所谓的“最优秀、最聪明的潜在暑期实习生”。吉姆在邓德·米夫林处于试用期。你知道，他收到了瑞安的警告。所以他打算通过在高尔夫球场上搞定一个潜在客户来挽回自己，安迪和凯文会帮他。
The rest of the Dendermifflin employees take the day off, despite a warning from Dwight, except for Angela, who ends her silent treatment of him when they find themselves alone in the office. It's perfect. That's a perfect summary. Thank you. You're welcome. Fast fact number one, Valley View High School, Pam's alma mater. Yeah. We got mail. Cavia R and Courtney K. asked, is Valley View High School a real high school and did you film there? And? It is a real high school. Ding, ding, ding. It's about nine miles north of Scranton in the suburb of Archbald. Their school mascot is the cougar. And their school colors appear to be blue and yellow, maybe blue and gold. Goldish yellow. I went to the website because it's the cougar, right? So you're saying it's yellow? I'm saying it's goldy yellow.
其余的邓德·米夫林员工休了一天假，尽管德怀特发出了警告，除了安吉拉，当他们发现办公室里只剩下他们两人时，她结束了对他的冷战。太完美了。这是一个完美的总结。谢谢。不客气。速记事实第一条，山景高中，帕姆的母校。是的。我们收到了邮件。卡维亚·R 和考特尼·K 问，山景高中是一所真实的高中吗？你们是在那里拍摄的吗？是吗？它是一所真实的高中。叮叮叮。它在斯克兰顿以北约九英里的阿奇博尔德郊区。他们的学校吉祥物是美洲狮。他们的学校颜色似乎是蓝色和黄色，也许是蓝色和金色。金黄色。我去了他们的网站，因为吉祥物是美洲狮，对吧？所以你是说它是黄色的？我说它是金黄色。
Goldish yellow. Okay. Their colors are blue and goldish yellow. Okay. We did not film at that school. Oh, no. We filmed at Birmingham High School in Van Nuys, California. By the way, in my research,
金黄色。好的。他们的颜色是蓝色和金黄色。好的。我们没有在那所学校拍摄。哦，不。我们在加利福尼亚州范奈斯的伯明翰高中拍摄的。顺便说一句，在我的研究中，
I discovered that the music videos for Gwen Stefani's Hollaback girl, Eminem's No Love, and Lil Wayne's prom queen, have also all filmed at Birmingham High School. Very, very popular location. Well, wait for it, Angela. Do you know what else is filmed there? Oh, God. Oh, let me guess. Let me guess.
我发现格温·史蒂芬妮的《Hollaback Girl》、阿姆的《No Love》和李尔·韦恩的《Prom Queen》的音乐录影带也都是在伯明翰高中拍摄的。非常、非常受欢迎的拍摄地。嗯，等着瞧，安吉拉。你知道还有什么在那里拍摄的吗？哦，天哪。哦，让我猜猜。让我猜猜。
Fast times at Ridgemont High. No. Greece. It's an office connection. Oh. Hmm. A 40-year-old virgin? An episode of Monk.
《开放的美国学府》。不。《油脂》。这是一个办公室联系。哦。嗯。《四十岁的老处男》？《神探阿蒙》的一集。
Oh! An episode of Monk! What is it with the office and Monk? I don't know. I really wish we had filmed back in like the 50s. Remember when they would do those crossover episodes and all of a sudden like Laverne and Shirley would be over at a, you know, the Fonzie's house? Yeah. It'd be like happy days Laverne and Shirley. What if we had a monk the office crossover? I wish we could go back in time and make that happen because we clearly use the same locations and the same guest stars. Have Tony Shaloo walk into the bullpen? Come on and interview someone. Maybe. Toby for being the Scranton Strangler. Yes! We did it. We did it. There it is, everybody. Your office reunion is also a monk crossover. Done. A little more information on the school. The school colors for Birmingham High School appear to be blue and white.
哦！《神探阿蒙》的一集！《办公室》和《神探阿蒙》到底是怎么回事？我不知道。我真希望我们是在 50 年代拍摄的。还记得他们做那些交叉剧集的时候吗？突然间，拉弗恩和雪莉会出现在方兹的家里？是的。那会是《欢乐时光》和《拉弗恩与雪莉》。如果我们有一个《神探阿蒙》和《办公室》的交叉剧集会怎样？我希望我们能回到过去让它发生，因为我们显然使用了相同的拍摄地和相同的客串明星。让托尼·夏尔赫布走进办公区？来吧，采访某个人。也许。托比因为是“斯克兰顿勒杀手”。是的！我们做到了。我们做到了。就是这样，各位。你们的《办公室》重聚也是一个《神探阿蒙》的交叉剧集。搞定。关于学校的更多信息。伯明翰高中的学校颜色似乎是蓝色和白色。
Kent Zabornak told me that we had to create all of our own signage and props for the school because we had to make sure, per our agreement with Birmingham High School, that none of of their actual logos or artwork or signage was seen. So there you go. We made it all. Everything hanging on the wall. Everything. Wowzers.
肯特·扎博纳克告诉我，我们必须为学校制作我们自己所有的标识和道具，因为我们必须确保，根据我们与伯明翰高中的协议，不能看到他们任何实际的标志、艺术品或标识。所以就是这样。我们制作了所有东西。挂在墙上的所有东西。所有东西。哇哦。
That's a lot. Listen, one can't told me that. As I was watching the episode, I was like, that's a lot of signs. Yeah. Check it out. Our art department was very busy this episode. They were. I'm moving us into FastFact number two.
那很多。听着，肯特告诉我的。当我观看这一集时，我在想，那有很多标识。是的。看看吧。我们的艺术部门这一集非常忙。他们确实很忙。我带大家进入速记事实第二条。
It's called golfing. Wait, wait. I sense a location breakdown. You are correct, Angela. And it's because we got a fan question from Sophie. D. Where did you film the scenes at the golf course? Because I'll have you notice. I looked, we never see a sign for where our guys are supposed to be. I googled, there is a country club of Scranton that offers golf as well as a few other golf courses near the Scranton area. I don't know which course this is
它叫打高尔夫球。等等，等等。我感觉到一个拍摄地解析。你是对的，安吉拉。这是因为我们收到了粉丝索菲·D 的提问。你们在哪里拍摄的高尔夫球场场景？因为我要提醒你。我看了，我们从来没看到我们的人应该在的地方有任何标志。我谷歌了一下，斯克兰顿乡村俱乐部提供高尔夫球，斯克兰顿地区附近还有其他几个高尔夫球场。我不知道这应该是
supposed to be, but we filmed at Vista Valencia golf course in Santa Clarita. It's a 27-hole facility. it has an 18-hole par-61 course and a nine-hole par-three course. Now here's what I found very interesting, maybe only to me. Let's hear it. The prices to play depend on what day you're playing and also what time you arrive. It's least expensive to go during the week in the afternoon. If you come first thing in the morning, it's going to cost you 2450 to walk the course or 3650 to ride it. If you come at three o'clock, it's only $13. to walk it and 2350 to ride it. But why is it more expensive to ride it?
哪一个球场，但我们在圣克拉丽塔的维斯塔瓦伦西亚高尔夫球场拍摄的。它是一个 27 洞的设施。它有一个 18 洞的标准杆 61 杆球场和一个 9 洞的标准杆 3 杆球场。现在这是我发现非常有趣的地方，也许只有我觉得有趣。说来听听。打球的价格取决于你打球的日子以及你到达的时间。在工作日下午去是最便宜的。如果你一大早就去，步行打球要 24.50 美元，乘车打球要 36.50 美元。如果你三点钟去，步行只要 13 美元，乘车只要 23.50 美元。但为什么乘车更贵呢？
Is it because it comes with the cart? I couldn't find that information. It seems like you'd flow faster if you're riding it than if you're walking it. Guess what, everybody. I don't know a lot about golfing. This is why I'm quiet because I'm like, I don't know. But here's the big kicker. And this is why I think you and I need to go to this golf course.
是因为它自带球车吗？我没能找到那个信息。看起来如果你乘车的话，流速会比步行快。猜猜看，各位。我对高尔夫球了解不多。这就是为什么我很安静，因为我在想，我不知道。但这是最大的重点。这就是为什么我觉得你和我需要去这个高尔夫球场。
Okay. They have something called foot golf. Foot golf? I'd never heard of it. It's a real thing. It's a combination of soccer and golf. And hacky sack. I think you could hacky and sack it in there.
好的。他们有一种叫“足式高尔夫”的东西。足式高尔夫？我从没听说过。这是真实存在的东西。它是足球和高尔夫的结合体。还有毽子。我觉得你可以在里面踢毽子。
There's basically a special golf course, but the holes are really big and you kick the ball down the course into the hole. Okay. Foot golf. Maybe we could fralph and then foot golf. I would foot golf if there was like a pony keg set up on like the eighth hole. So like you kick your ball, then you have a beer, then you kick your ball. What's a pony keg? A pony keg?
基本上有一个特殊的高尔夫球场，但洞很大，你把球踢进球场里的洞里。好的。足式高尔夫。也许我们可以先打高尔夫，然后足式高尔夫。如果第八洞有小桶啤酒的话，我会去玩足式高尔夫。所以就像你踢球，然后喝杯啤酒，然后再踢球。什么是小桶啤酒？小桶啤酒？
Isn't that? Don't you all have pony kegs? It's like a party kegs, like a mini keg of beer. A pony keg? Anyone? Sam, Cassie, pony keg? Ever heard of it? A pony keg is a mini keg?
不是吗？你们难道没有小桶啤酒吗？就像派对小桶，就像迷你桶的啤酒。小桶啤酒？有人吗？萨姆，卡西，小桶啤酒？听说过吗？小桶啤酒是迷你桶？
Yeah. It's like a baby keg. No, you're right. Pony keg is a quarter keg. Yeah. Thank you. What's a half keg called? Silence.
是的。就像婴儿桶。不，你是对的。小桶啤酒是四分之一桶。是的。谢谢。半桶叫什么？沉默。
I don't find any cool names. Oh. So you can get up. Here are your choices. Pony keg, half keg, keg. Hmm. I feel like they sell more pony kegs just because the name is cute, but I don't know. And you can carry them if you're on the petite side.
我没找到什么酷名字。哦。所以你可以选择。这是你的选择。小桶啤酒，半桶，桶。嗯。我觉得他们卖更多小桶啤酒只是因为名字很可爱，但我不知道。而且如果你身材娇小，你可以带着它们。
Like myself. Oh, we're learning so much today. So much. Fast fact number three. Angela, you were very, very, very pregnant in this episode. Yeah, I was. When you were filming your scenes with Dwight in the office, Lee Eisenberg had the flu.
像我一样。哦，我们今天学到了很多。很多。速记事实第三条。安吉拉，你在这一集里非常、非常、非常怀孕。是的，我是。当你和德怀特在办公室拍摄场景时，李·艾森伯格得了流感。
He was not there that day. Only Gene Stepnitsky was on the set. When they got into the editing bay to edit the episode, Lee Eisenberg was there. And he said, you guys, why don't we have any wider shots of these scenes? And Dave Rogers and Gene had to remind him because Angela's belly was very hard to hide. So all of these shots are like Angela from like the shoulders up. But here is what else I found in my.
那天他不在。只有吉恩·斯图普尼茨基在片场。当他们进入剪辑室剪辑这一集时，李·艾森伯格在场。他说，伙计们，为什么我们没有这些场景的广角镜头？戴夫·罗杰斯和吉恩不得不提醒他，因为安吉拉的肚子很难隐藏。所以所有这些镜头都是安吉拉从肩膀往上的。但这是我在我的
Googling Angela. What? By the time this episode aired, you had given birth. I know. You gave birth five days before this episode aired. That is true. Well, lady, I have a really fun story from this episode. And it's something that involves the golf course.
谷歌搜索安吉拉时发现的其他东西。什么？在这一集播出时，你已经生了。我知道。你在这一集播出前五天生了孩子。那是真的。好吧，女士，我有一个关于这一集的非常有趣的故事。它涉及高尔夫球场。
I had no scenes at the golf course, but I went to visit the fellas. I was doing a whole series at this time on NBC.com called Adventures with Angela. and Creed and Ed had written a song for my baby. I mean, with the banjo, the guitar, the whole thing. So I went to the golf course on Monday, on their lunch, and we sat out in this beautiful green, like grassy area, and they sang to me. And not only that, I couldn't remember how we got there.
我在高尔夫球场没有场景，但我去探望了那些家伙。我当时在 NBC.com 上做了一个完整的系列节目，叫《安吉拉的冒险》。克里德和埃德为我的宝宝写了一首歌。我是说，用班卓琴、吉他，整套东西。所以我周一在他们的午餐时间去了高尔夫球场，我们坐在那个美丽的绿色草地上，他们为我唱歌。不仅如此，我不记得我们是怎么到那里的。
I was like, I don't remember driving to this place or where it was. And you know when you're a passenger how you don't really pay attention as much? Yeah. So I found this email that I had written to John Krasinski where I said, hey John, I'll see you Monday. I can't wait. Creed is picking me up in his sports car. Should I be scared? And we're going to come and have lunch and he and Ed are going to sing a song for my little little little little little two-seater sports car. And they sang this song to me and it was on NBC.com. And Jenna, they gave me a copy. and I tore my house up looking for this this week. I have ransacked the whole house. I know I have it somewhere and I really wanted to play it for you guys. But Joya, who worked with us over at NBC.com, is on the case. She's going to find it.
我当时想，我不记得开车去那个地方或它在哪里了。你知道当你是个乘客时，你不会太注意，对吧？是的。所以我找到了这封我写给约翰·克拉辛斯基的邮件，我说，嘿约翰，周一见。我等不及了。克里德开着他的跑车来接我。我应该害怕吗？我们要去吃午饭，他和埃德要为我的小、小、小、小、小双座跑车唱一首歌。他们为我唱了这首歌，它在 NBC.com 上。而且珍娜，他们给了我一份拷贝。我这周把房子翻了个底朝天找它。我把整个房子都搜遍了。我知道它在某处，我真的很想为你们播放它。但乔亚，那个在 NBC.com 和我们一起工作的人，正在处理这件事。她会找到它的。
And hopefully maybe in a revisited I'll be able to play it for you guys because it's really special. And I'm just heartbroken that I couldn't find it. That is so cool, Angela. I remember seeing the video of that. so I really do hope you find it. Me too, me too. It was so cute. I remember Creed started off with Angela's baby.
希望也许在重温节目中我能为你们播放它，因为它真的很特别。我因为没能找到它而心碎。那太酷了，安吉拉。我记得看过那个视频。所以我真的希望你能找到它。我也是，我也是。它太可爱了。我记得克里德是以“安吉拉的宝宝”开始的。
It was just so fun. Well, Ange, that's really all I had for this. I guess I have something that could be considered half a fast fact that I could throw in there. Half a fast fact. What you got? My half a fast fact is that Toby was not in this episode because he was busy writing the season finale. Ooh, that is a good one. Well, I have a little Kinsey tidbit.
它太有趣了。好吧，安吉，这就是我关于这一集的所有内容了。我想我有一些可以被认为是半个速记事实的东西，我可以加进去。半个速记事实。你有什么？我的半个速记事实是托比没在这一集中，因为他忙着写季终集。噢，那是一个很好的事实。好吧，我有一个小小的金赛花絮。
Ooh, guess who found her script of Job Fair? This lady! Oh my gosh, Angela, this is very exciting to me because I have a couple of fan questions that I didn't know the answer to you, but I bet the answers are in the script. Oh, oh, let me get it. I'll get it. And let's go to break and we'll come back and jump into some job fair. I like it. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
噢，猜猜谁找到了她的《招聘会》剧本？这位女士！哦，天哪，安吉拉，这对我来说非常令人兴奋，因为我有几个粉丝问题我不知道答案，但我敢打赌答案就在剧本里。哦，哦，让我拿来。我去拿。我们去休息一下，回来后深入探讨《招聘会》。我喜欢。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。
Sometimes it can feel like everyone else has it all together. Their love life, even whether they're married or dating. dating or single, like they've got it figured out. But the truth is, I think we're all still figuring it out. No matter where you are in your romantic journey, therapy is kind of great because you have someone to talk it out with, get advice from, kind of help you determine what you want and take some of that pressure off yourself. Yeah, and maybe to help unpack some elements of the past that might be holding you back, well, better help therapists work according to a strict code of conduct. they are fully licensed in the U.S.
有时感觉好像其他人都把生活打理得井井有条。他们的爱情生活，无论是结婚、约会还是单身，好像他们都搞定了。但事实是，我觉得我们都在摸索。无论你在浪漫旅程的哪个阶段，治疗都是很棒的，因为你有人可以倾诉，可以寻求建议，可以帮助你确定你想要什么，并减轻你身上的一些压力。是的，也许还可以帮助解开过去可能阻碍你的一些因素，嗯，BetterHelp 的治疗师按照严格的行为准则工作。他们在美利坚合众国拥有完全执照。
And BetterHelp will offer you the therapist match commitment. You get a short questionnaire, you say your preferences, and they'll match you with someone. But guess what? If you don't like them, you can switch to a different therapist at any time. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHELP.com.
BetterHelp 将为你提供治疗师匹配承诺。你填写一份简短的问卷，说明你的偏好，他们会为你匹配一个人。但猜猜怎么着？如果你不喜欢他们，你可以随时更换不同的治疗师。拥有超过 30,000 名治疗师，BetterHelp 是全球最大的在线治疗平台，已为全球超过 500 万人提供服务。注册并在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 获得 10% 的折扣。那是 BetterHELP.com
slash office ladies. All right, we are back. I have my script of job fair and Jenna right out of the gate. I have a question for you. What is it? Did you notice that this episode does not have a cold open? I kind of did, Angela. We have a scene before the credits, but it's on plot.
/officeladies。好了，我们回来了。我有我的《招聘会》剧本，珍娜，开门见山。我有一个问题要问你。是什么？你注意到这一集没有冷开场吗？我有点注意到了，安吉拉。我们在片头字幕前有一个场景，但它是关于情节的。
It's on story. It's not one of those standalone comedic cold opens that we're used to. I did notice. That's right. We just kind of get right into the meat of the episode, right? Yes. There was a cold open, and I'm going to read you a little bit about what it was, okay? Okay. So in the cold open, you hear this screaming noise from the men's restroom. And everyone in the bullpen kind of grumbles like,
它是关于故事的。它不是我们习惯的那种独立的喜剧冷开场。我确实注意到了。没错。我们只是直接进入了剧集的重点，对吧？是的。确实有一个冷开场，我要读给你听听它是什么，好吗？好的。所以在冷开场中，你听到男洗手间传来尖叫声。办公区里的每个人都抱怨说，
oh, not again. And Michael comes out. He's just exasperated because he has dropped everything that was in his pockets into the toilet, like everything. He lists it off. He dropped his cell phone, his tip calculator, his wallet, his white strips, candy corn, his eraser. His eraser. and then Jim says, what about your car keys? And Michael says, I threw them into the toilet out of anger. And this leads him to this light bulb moment, because I guess this happens quite frequently for Michael. And he goes into his office and he comes out and he's like, guys,
噢，又来了。迈克尔走了出来。他只是非常恼火，因为他把口袋里所有的东西都掉进了马桶里，就像所有的东西。他列举了出来。他掉了手机、小费计算器、钱包、美白牙贴、玉米糖、橡皮擦。他的橡皮擦。然后吉姆说，那你的车钥匙呢？迈克尔说，我因为生气把它们扔进马桶里了。这让他产生了一个灵光一现的时刻，因为我想这种情况对迈克尔来说经常发生。他走进办公室，然后出来，他说，伙计们，
I have invented this amazing invention. And he says it's the mesh toilet guard to go over the toilet. And then the camera pans past him. And he has just cut out the back of his desk chair. That's mesh. into like a circle and he's like, who's going to volunteer? This is going to be great. It's like, wait, portable, reusable.
我发明了这个惊人的发明。他说这是放在马桶上的网状马桶护罩。然后摄像机扫过他。他刚刚剪掉了办公椅的靠背。那是网状的。剪成了一个圆圈，他说，谁要自愿？这会很棒。就像，等等，便携、可重复使用。
You could just put it in your dishwasher. So what? He's going to start using the bathroom through this meshy cover. But he's thrilled. He thinks he's going to be a gazillionaire with the mesh toilet guard. I don't know where to begin. I know. So that was the cold open that they didn't end up using.
你可以把它放进洗碗机里。所以呢？他要开始透过这个网状罩子使用洗手间了。但他很兴奋。他认为他会靠这个网状马桶护罩成为亿万富翁。我不知道从何说起。我知道。所以这就是他们最终没用的冷开场。
And they just jumped right into the episode. Here's the thing. I can't remember if we shot that, but I remember that joke, probably from the table read because we must have read it. Yeah. I remember the joke that Michael threw his keys in out of anger. That was my favorite part. So this isn't in the deleted scenes then.
他们直接跳进了剧集。事情是这样的。我不记得我们是否拍过那个，但我记得那个笑话，可能是从剧本朗读时记得的，因为我们肯定读过。是的。我记得迈克尔因为生气把钥匙扔进去的那个笑话。那是我的最爱。所以这不在删减片段里。
It's not in the deleted scenes, but it is in the script, but they didn't use it. Hmm. Just a little trivia for you since I have the script. The script is paying off already. I'm excited about it. The way this episode does start is Michael comes out of his office. He's dressed in his jeans. Yeah, it's got sneakers on.
它不在删减片段里，但它在剧本里，只是他们没用它。嗯。给你一点小知识，既然我有剧本。剧本已经派上用场了。我很兴奋。这一集的开始方式是迈克尔从办公室出来。他穿着牛仔裤。是的，穿着运动鞋。
He's trying to look young and hip. I think so. Pam and Oscar and Daryl are all around reception, and we find out that today, the four of them, will be attending the job fair at Valleyview High School in search of new interns. Because he wants to euthanize the office. Well, there is a deleted scene where Michael shares
他试图看起来年轻时髦。我想是这样。帕姆、奥斯卡和达里尔都在接待处周围，我们发现今天他们四个人将参加山景高中的招聘会，寻找新的实习生。因为他想让办公室“安乐死”。嗯，有一个删减场景是迈克尔分享
that he's been really depressed since Ryan left. Sam, can you play that? I am depressed. Since Ryan left, I've been going through emptiness syndrome. And I call it that because that's the way I felt when empty nest went off the air. I am lonely. And I need a new Ryan. That's amazing.
他自从瑞安离开后就一直很沮丧。萨姆，你能播放那个吗？我很沮丧。自从瑞安离开后，我就一直经历着“空巢综合症”。我称之为那个，因为当《空巢》停播时我就是这种感觉。我很孤独。我需要一个新的瑞安。太棒了。
Yeah. And so he sees this job fair at the local high school is his way to recruit some young buddy. Michael just wants a younger sibling. Yeah, we had a fan question from Thomas V. How did they decide who got to go to the job fair? This was one of those instances where they would look at the cast and they would say, who haven't we seen together yet or in a while? And that's kind of how they hold the names. Because something I noticed is that there is not technically a salesperson represented. So there's someone from accounting. There's someone from the warehouse. Front reception. who Michael refers to as the eye candy. And Michael, who I guess could also cover sales. Right.
是的。所以他看到当地高中的这个招聘会是他招募年轻伙伴的方式。迈克尔只是想要一个弟弟妹妹。是的，我们有一个来自托马斯·V 的粉丝问题。他们是怎么决定谁去招聘会的？这是他们观察演员阵容并说，我们还没见过谁在一起，或者谁有一段时间没见了，这就是他们决定人选的方式。因为我注意到的一件事是，技术上没有销售人员代表。所以有一个来自会计部的。有一个来自仓库的。前台接待。迈克尔称之为“养眼”的人。还有迈克尔，我想他也可以负责销售。对。
He was a really good salesman. He was. Yeah. But yeah, this was more about pairing of people and characters and who would make a great foil for Michael at the job fair. Well, we know why I couldn't go. Yeah. You would have just to shoot four floating heads.
他是个非常好的推销员。他确实是。是的。但是的，这更多是关于人物和角色的配对，以及谁会在招聘会上成为迈克尔的绝佳陪衬。嗯，我们知道为什么我不能去。是的。那只会拍到四个漂浮的脑袋。
It would have just been four heads in a high school auditorium. because I was super prags. Okay, so that's who went to the high school. But now we have this other kind of odd pairing headed to the golf course. It's Jim, Andy, and Kevin. And Jim's on probation. He's got to make this big, big sale. And this is his rag-tack team that I guess is going to help him.
那只会是高中礼堂里的四个脑袋。因为我当时怀孕了。好的，所以这就是去高中的人。但现在我们有另一个奇怪的配对前往高尔夫球场。是吉姆、安迪和凯文。吉姆在试用期。他必须完成这笔大生意。这是他的“破烂”团队，我想他们会帮他。
Yeah, things start off a little, how would you put it, oddly? Because the first thing that Andy does is insult Mr. McGuire, their potential client, because he's wearing a Dartmouth sweatshirt. He tells him to take it off and that his grandfather would be spinning in his urn. If he knew he was, you know, golfing with a Dartmouth alum, there's clearly some real rivalry here between Cornell and Dartmouth.
是的，事情开始得有点，你会怎么说，奇怪？因为安迪做的第一件事就是侮辱他们的潜在客户麦奎尔先生，因为他穿着达特茅斯运动衫。他让他脱掉它，说如果他知道他在和达特茅斯校友打高尔夫球，他爷爷会在骨灰盒里打转。康奈尔和达特茅斯之间显然存在真正的竞争。
Well, I looked it up. Mm-hmm. It's this big college football rivalry between the Cornell Big Red and the Dartmouth Big Green. I guess these two schools were major football powers back in the day. There's since been a split in the divisions. the football divisions, but prior to the split, Cornell kind of dominated the national championships. They won in 1915, 1921, 22, 23, and 39.
嗯，我查过了。嗯。这是康奈尔大红队和达特茅斯大绿队之间的一场大型大学橄榄球竞争。我想这两所学校在过去都是主要的橄榄球强校。从那以后，分部发生了分裂。橄榄球分部，但在分裂之前，康奈尔在全国锦标赛中占据主导地位。他们在 1915、1921、1923 和 1939 年获胜。
Dartmouth won once in 1925. So Cornell was dominating the Ivy League. Yes. But then, in 1940, there was this infamous game, Amge. Oh. Cornell had a 16-game winning streak. And this was like a school record. They were about to win the national championship with a score of seven to three.
达特茅斯在 1925 年赢过一次。所以康奈尔统治了常春藤联盟。是的。但是，在 1940 年，发生了一场臭名昭著的比赛，安吉。哦。康奈尔有 16 连胜。这就像一个学校记录。他们即将以 7 比 3 的比分赢得全国冠军。
But guess what they did? What? They did a film review of the game and found out that Cornell had inadvertently used five downs instead of four. And they had to forfeit the game to Dartmouth. Oh. According to the ESPN College Football Encyclopedia, they consider this to be the second greatest moment in college football history. and it is commonly referred to as the fifth down game. Hmm.
但你猜他们做了什么？什么？他们对比赛进行了录像回顾，发现康奈尔无意中用了五次进攻机会而不是四次。他们不得不把比赛输给达特茅斯。哦。根据 ESPN 大学橄榄球百科全书，他们认为这是大学橄榄球史上第二伟大的时刻。它通常被称为“第五次进攻比赛”。嗯。
So I guess that's why Andy's grandfather was spinning in his urn. Well, Mindy went to Dartmouth, so she might have known some of that rivalry. I have to think that might have come up in the writer's room. I wonder. And there are deleted scenes that support this. Jim shares that, you know what, he's bringing Andy on purpose because he knew Andy would flip out about Mr. McGuire being a Dartmouth guy. and then they would have sort of this like common enemy
所以我猜这就是为什么安迪的爷爷会在骨灰盒里打转。嗯，敏迪去了达特茅斯，所以她可能知道一些那种竞争。我不得不认为这可能在编剧室里被提出来过。我想知道。而且有删减场景支持这一点。吉姆分享说，你知道吗，他故意带上安迪，因为他知道安迪会因为麦奎尔先生是达特茅斯的人而抓狂。然后他们会有一种像共同敌人一样的东西
that it would be bonding for Mr. McGuire and Jim because Andy's an idiot. Well, that doesn't track because Jim seems so horrified by Andy's comment to Mr. McGuire. Exactly. So then there's this scene where, you know, Mr. McGuire is like, gosh, this guy and Jim's like, I know, Cornell, right? Oh, I get it.
这对麦奎尔先生和吉姆来说是一种联结，因为安迪是个白痴。嗯，那说不通，因为吉姆看起来对安迪对麦奎尔先生的评论感到非常震惊。正是如此。所以有一个场景，麦奎尔先生说，天哪，这家伙，吉姆说，我知道，康奈尔，对吧？哦，我明白了。
Oh, yeah. Jim was being diabolical. He had a whole plan. Right. Best friends through a country. I'm an enemy. That's right. Look at us. We're buddies now. We're pals. Give me your business. Don't pay attention to that Cornell idiot. Thank God you have me here. Yeah, don't pay attention to that idiot who also works at my company. I don't know if this was a great plan, Jim. Well, part of his strategy.
哦，是的。吉姆当时很邪恶。他有一个完整的计划。对。通过一个国家成为最好的朋友。我是敌人。没错。看看我们。我们现在是哥们了。我们是伙伴。把你的生意给我。别理那个康奈尔白痴。谢天谢地你有我在。是的，别理那个也在我公司工作的白痴。我不知道这是否是一个伟大的计划，吉姆。嗯，他策略的一部分。
Andy also can't shake hands with Mr. McGuire because his hands are covered in blisters. Blisties. Yeah. He's nifty gifties. He's blisties. He loves a little IES on things. I got the low down on how they made those blisters. Oh, let's hear it. Who did it? It was our makeup artist LeBern. She applied the makeup. It took her about 20 or 30 minutes to do it. She started by putting coloring on his hand, so she kind of painted his hands red. Then she covered it with something called RCMA scar making material. She said it's really, really tricky to apply because as soon as it dries, it's set. You can't move it and it dries really, really fast. So she would put it on really quickly with a tiny, metal spatula and tweezers, and that afterwards, Ed was not allowed to wash his hands or get them
安迪也不能和麦奎尔先生握手，因为他的手上全是水泡。水泡。是的。他是“水泡小能手”。他喜欢在东西后面加“IES”。我了解到了他们是怎么制作那些水泡的。哦，说来听听。谁做的？是我们的化妆师勒伯恩。她涂了化妆品。她花了大约 20 或 30 分钟才完成。她先在手上涂上颜色，所以她把他的手涂成了红色。然后她用一种叫 RCMA 疤痕制作材料的东西覆盖它。她说它非常、非常难涂，因为一旦干了，它就定型了。你不能移动它，而且它干得非常、非常快。所以她会用一个小金属刮刀和镊子很快地把它涂上去，之后，埃德不被允许洗手或弄湿它们。
wet. How do you go to the bathroom? I mean, I guess he just didn't wash his hands after. I hope he didn't awkward, get them wet in any other way. Do you always wash your hands after you go to the bathroom? Yes. Even at home? Yes. After you pee, at home, you wash your hands. You wash your hands. You your hands with soap and water every time? Every time. Every time I rinse them and I have a little pump. Or I have a big bar and I rub my hand over the bar soap every time. It was drilled into me by my mom.
你怎么上厕所？我的意思是，我猜他之后只是没洗手。我希望他没有尴尬地以任何其他方式弄湿它们。你每次上完厕所都洗手吗？是的。即使在家里？是的。小便后，在家里，你洗手吗？你洗手。你每次都用肥皂和水洗手吗？每次。每次我都冲洗它们，我有一个小泵。或者我有一块大肥皂，我每次都用手搓肥皂。这是我妈妈灌输给我的。
I rinse my hands every time. And I make Isabel. So it's just like automatic. I feel like it's really clear now that I don't always wash my hands after I pee at home. I feel like maybe we were going to bond over something that now we're not bonding over. Oh, no. And now I just think you're disgusting.
我每次都冲洗我的手。我让伊莎贝尔也这样做。所以这就像自动的。我觉得现在很清楚了，我并不总是会在家里小便后洗手。我觉得也许我们本来要因为某件事而建立联系，现在我们却没建立联系。哦，不。现在我觉得你很恶心。
I guess now you're going to have to worry when you come over to my house. Did I wash my hands after I? I always wash my hands after poop, always. I never wipe a poop and then not wash my hands everybody. I feel like I want that to be clear. Well, I'm not going to worry. I'm just not going to touch your hands or anything your hands touch. I don't know how I feel about this conversation.
我想现在你来我家时得担心了。我上完厕所洗手了吗？我上完大号总是洗手的，总是。我从来不会擦完屁股不洗手，大家。我觉得我有必要澄清这一点。好吧，我不会担心的。我只是不会碰你的手，也不会碰你手碰过的任何东西。我不知道该怎么看待这段对话。
We should probably segue out of it. Well, I'll say this about blisters. Okay. It might fall under the heading of things you already know, but as the emerging amateur medical expert of office ladies, you should never pop a blister. Oh. The fluid inside your blister has healing properties. And it also protects the affected area so that you won't get an infection. so you really want the fluid to stay in there as long as possible and just let the blister heal itself.
我们还是换个话题吧。好吧，关于水泡，我来说说。好吧。这可能属于你已经知道的事情，但作为《办公室》的业余医学专家，你永远不应该挑破水泡。哦。水泡里的液体有愈合作用。它还能保护受影响的区域，这样你就不会感染。所以你真的希望液体尽可能长时间地留在里面，让水泡自己愈合。
Don't pop it. I did not know that. I feel like I have popped many a blister. This is so interesting. I'm not going to pop a blister now. I'm just going to look at it and say Jenna told me to let it do its thing. So I'm going to let it do its thing. I might start washing my hands after I pee at home.
别挑破它。我以前不知道。我觉得我挑破过很多水泡。这太有趣了。我现在不会挑破水泡了。我只会看着它，对自己说，珍娜告诉我让它顺其自然。所以我打算让它顺其自然。我可能以后在家上完厕所会开始洗手了。
I hope so. Well, now Mr. McGuire wants to make this golf game more interesting. So he suggests that they make a little wager. Why don't they do a little betting? Oh my gosh. This is music to Kevin's ears. Kevin's like, what, what? Mr. McGuire suggests $10 a hole.
希望如此。好吧，现在麦奎尔先生想让这场高尔夫比赛更有趣。所以他建议他们打个小赌。他们为什么不赌一把呢？天哪。这对凯文来说简直是天籁之音。凯文心想，什么，什么？麦奎尔先生建议每洞10美元。
But Kevin, Jenna, he lists all of these games. I know. I wrote them down. You want to hear what they are? I do. All right. He says, you want to play skins, AC Doocy, bingo bingo bongo,
但是凯文，珍娜，他列举了所有这些游戏。我知道。我把它们记下来了。你想听听是什么吗？我想听。好吧。他说，你想玩Skins, AC Doocy, bingo bingo bongo,
Sandy's, Barkies, Wulf. Arneys, don't forget Arnie's. Oh, I'm so sorry. I forgot Arne's. I looked it up. These are all real ways to bet on golf. They're real. I mean, I have an explanation for all of them. I won't go into it. But fascinating. I didn't even realize you could do this much golf betting. Clearly, there's so much golf gambling. And you know what? It tracks that Kevin would know. Yeah, this is bringing up his whole gambling thing. Mm-hmm. And he admits that he's going to take the
Sandy's, Barkies, Wulf。Arneys，别忘了Arnie's。哦，我很抱歉。我忘了Arnie's。我查过了。这些都是真正的高尔夫博彩方式。它们是真的。我的意思是，我对它们都有解释。我就不细说了。但很迷人。我甚至没意识到你可以进行这么多高尔夫博彩。显然，高尔夫赌博非常多。你知道吗？凯文会知道这一点是有迹可循的。是的，这勾起了他整个赌博的事情。嗯哼。而且他承认他要拿走
petty cash from Oscar and use it to turn it into next month's rent. So he is gambling with Dunderc. Mifflin's Petty Cash. Should we move on to this job fair lady? Yes, let's move on to the job fair. Pam has to walk down memory lane for high school and you learn a lot about her. Yeah, she has this talking head where she says this gym reminds her of all the time she pretended to have PMS to get out of playing sports. In particular volleyball, but yet in company picnic, she's like a volleyball pro. So what's happening? Oh, have we ever gotten more male? I feel seen. Thank you for everyone that wrote in. As soon as Pam said that, I was like, what the heck? I know. Chelsea B wrote in this theory on why it still tracks that she would have pretended to have PMS while also being a volleyball champion. And I loved it.
奥斯卡的零用现金，并用它来赚下个月的房租。所以他在用邓德·米夫林的零用现金赌博。我们应该继续谈谈这个招聘会吗？是的，让我们继续谈谈招聘会。帕姆必须重温高中时光，你会了解到很多关于她的事情。是的，她有一个采访镜头，她说这个体育馆让她想起她为了逃避体育课而假装有经前综合症的所有时光。特别是排球，但后来在公司野餐时，她就像个排球高手。所以发生了什么？哦，我们收到过更多的邮件吗？我觉得被关注了。谢谢所有写信来的人。帕姆一说那话，我就想，搞什么鬼？我知道。切尔西·B写信提出了一个理论，解释为什么她既假装有经前综合症又是排球冠军，这仍然说得通。我很喜欢这个理论。
So here is Chelsea's theory. She says, people always point out the continuity error that Pam says she faked cramps so she wouldn't have to play volleyball in gym class. However, maybe Pam faked cramps because she didn't want to have to play volleyball with her classmates who weren't very good at it. As a former athlete myself, I can tell you I wouldn't have had much fun playing my sport with people who sucked at it. So in my opinion, it's not surprising that she'd try to get out of it. Well, Chelsea, I think you're being very kind. What? I love that Chelsea is like, Pam is such a badass volleyball player, that she cannot handle a gym class volleyball game. I mean, come on in high school.
所以这是切尔西的理论。她说，人们总是指出帕姆说她假装抽筋以逃避体育课排球比赛的连续性错误。然而，也许帕姆假装抽筋是因为她不想和那些排球打得不好的同学一起打球。作为一名前运动员，我可以告诉你，和那些打得很烂的人一起玩我的运动，我不会觉得有什么乐趣。所以在我看来，她想逃避这一点并不奇怪。好吧，切尔西，我觉得你太善良了。什么？我喜欢切尔西说，帕姆是个如此厉害的排球运动员，以至于她无法忍受体育课的排球比赛。我的意思是，拜托，在高中。
Like, they would have pulled you out and put you in varsity volleyball. You would have been separated from the Lamos. No, this was gym class. This was just like everybody get exercise in gym class. We're going to play volleyball today. So Pam was probably on the varsity team, but she just didn't want to have to play in gym class. It was a waste of her time and talent.
就像，他们会把你拉出来放进校队排球队。你会和那些菜鸟分开的。不，这是体育课。这就像体育课上每个人都要锻炼。我们今天要打排球。所以帕姆可能在校队，但她只是不想在体育课上打球。这对她的时间和天赋来说是一种浪费。
Okay, Chelsea. Okay. Okay. Well, I'm living for your piece of mail, Chelsea. I appreciated it. You made her day, Chelsea. Well, there's another deleted scene with Pam as she's going through the high school. She walks past the sports trophy case and there's a big old photo of Roy Anderson, the big jock, you know, in high school. And she looks at it and says, nine years of my life. I remember shooting that. Mm-hmm. They had done this little Photoshop of David Denman. Yeah, in a high school photo. And Oscar has a deleted talking head where he says, No, surprisingly enough, I did not always dream of being an accountant at Dunder Mifflin. In high school, I was just a normal kid. I made decent grades, played bass in a new wave band,
好吧，切尔西。好吧。好吧，我为你这封邮件而活，切尔西。我很感激。你让她的一天变得很美好，切尔西。好吧，还有一个帕姆的删减片段，当她走过高中时。她走过体育奖杯陈列柜，那里有一张罗伊·安德森的大照片，你知道，高中时的大运动员。她看着它说，我生命中的九年。我记得拍那张照片。嗯哼。他们把大卫·丹曼的照片PS到了高中照片里。是的，奥斯卡有一个删减的采访镜头，他说，不，令人惊讶的是，我并不总是梦想成为邓德·米夫林的会计。在高中时，我只是个普通的孩子。成绩不错，在一支新浪潮乐队里弹贝斯，
had a poster of Kim Bassinger over my bed. Oh, how I wanted to be Kim Bessinger. That is a great talking head. It was. I wish it had stayed in. Michael is feeling pretty confident about his booth, so much so that the only thing that he brought was a blank piece of paper. So it's the four of them sitting at a table with a blank piece of paper in front of them. Well, he says a blank sheet of paper equals endless possibilities.
床头贴着金·贝辛格的海报。哦，我多么想成为金·贝辛格。那是一个很棒的采访镜头。确实。我希望它能保留下来。迈克尔对他们的展位感觉很自信，以至于他唯一带来的东西就是一张白纸。所以他们四个人坐在桌子旁，面前放着一张白纸。好吧，他说一张白纸等于无限的可能性。
It's conceptual. That's what he says. Meanwhile, the booth next door has like a basketball hoop. And then one has like a popcorn machine. No one is going to stop by this booth. And there's a deleted scene, Jenna, that goes. on for so long. I loved it so much of just a steady stream of kids walking past you guys, not stopping at all. And the only one that stops briefly sets down as popcorn like container
这是概念性的。他是这么说的。与此同时，隔壁的展位有一个篮球架。然后另一个有爆米花机。没有人会停在这个展位前。而且有一个删减片段，珍娜，持续了很长时间。我非常喜欢它，就是一群孩子不断地走过你们，根本没有停下来。唯一一个短暂停止的人放下他的爆米花容器
and just leaves it there like trash. It spills over and then Oscar is just tidying up this kid's trash. Angela, we had so much fun shooting these scenes. I so loved getting to be on location with these three guys. We had the best time. They gave all the background actors the direction that they should be like having a great time and smiling and high energy at all the other booths so that when you got to ours, it was particularly quiet and sad looking. It really, really works. It was cracking me up. Should we go back over to Dunder Mifflin and see what everyone else is up to? Yes. Well, let me tell you what they're up to. They're up to trying to sneak out of work. I mean, Meredith and Phyllis are stirring the pot. Michael is gone. They don't want to stay the whole day. No. And Creed has a great line where he says
然后就像垃圾一样把它留在那里。它溢出来了，然后奥斯卡就在清理这个孩子的垃圾。安吉拉，我们拍摄这些场景时玩得很开心。我非常喜欢和这三个人一起在现场。我们度过了最美好的时光。他们给所有的背景演员指示，说他们在其他展位应该玩得很开心，面带微笑，充满活力，这样当你来到我们这里时，它就显得特别安静和悲伤。这真的很有效。这让我笑得前仰后合。我们应该回到邓德·米夫林看看其他人都在做什么吗？是的。好吧，让我告诉你他们在做什么。他们正试图溜出工作岗位。我的意思是，梅雷迪思和菲利斯在煽风点火。迈克尔走了。他们不想待一整天。不。而且克里德有一句很棒的台词，他说
he finished his work months ago. I loved that. Like, what is he doing? Dwight reminds them all that when Michael is gone, Jim is in charge. And when Jim is gone, Andy and Dwight are in charge. And when Andy is gone, you answer to Dwight. And Stanley's like, I don't give a crap. I'm out. I love so much that moment when Stanley walks out the door. I did too. And Dwight doesn't know what to do. You We have said we feel like Stanley is the person, Dwight is like, I am not going to like mess with Stanley. But Dwight asserts to the whole office, look, you guys, the American workday ends at five o'clock. And so you must stay until the end of the workday, period. Or I'll tattle on you. Right. Back at the high school, Pam is chatting up a young prospective intern. He's actually
他在几个月前就完成了工作。我喜欢那个。就像，他在做什么？德怀特提醒他们所有人，当迈克尔不在时，吉姆负责。当吉姆不在时，安迪和德怀特负责。当安迪不在时，你听命于德怀特。斯坦利说，我才不在乎。我走了。我非常喜欢斯坦利走出门口的那一刻。我也喜欢。德怀特不知道该怎么办。我们说过我们觉得斯坦利是那种人，德怀特心想，我才不会去惹斯坦利。但德怀特向整个办公室断言，听着，伙计们，美国的工作日到五点结束。所以你们必须待到工作日结束，句号。否则我就去告发你们。对。回到高中，帕姆正在和一个年轻的潜在实习生聊天。他实际上
interested in Dunder Mifflin. And Michael signals her to stop. Yeah. Well, not just that. He goes up to this kid whose name is Justin. He says, I don't think this is the job for you. Paper should be more of a hobby for you. And then he takes away the kid's pamphlet that he was looking at. Yeah. We had a fan catch about it, though, from Harmgen V and Alyssa C. If Michael only brought one sheet of paper to the job fair, where did the brochure come from that Pam gave to Justin and Michael took away? Hmm. Good question. I mean, clearly they brought a brochure. I felt like the paper was their prop, was the thing that was supposed to be the eye-catching moment as people walked by. So maybe under the desk, Pam had some additional materials. When the paper makes you stop in your tracks to talk to these people at their booth, then you get a pamphlet. Okay. I like it. Michael is furious that Justin signed his name on their blank piece of paper. He's even, even more furious to learn that Pam only brought the one. Yeah, and Pam's like, excuse me? I love that she totally calls him out on it. I know. She said, Michael, do you not remember?
对邓德·米夫林感兴趣。迈克尔示意她停下来。是的。好吧，不仅如此。他走到这个名叫贾斯汀的孩子面前。他说，我不认为这是适合你的工作。纸张对你来说应该更像是一种爱好。然后他拿走了孩子正在看的宣传册。是的。不过我们有一个粉丝发现了这一点，来自Harmgen V和Alyssa C。如果迈克尔只带了一张纸去招聘会，帕姆给贾斯汀的那本宣传册是从哪里来的，后来又被迈克尔拿走了？嗯。好问题。我的意思是，显然他们带了一本宣传册。我觉得那张纸是他们的道具，是当人们走过时应该吸引眼球的东西。所以也许在桌子下面，帕姆还有一些额外的材料。当那张纸让你停下脚步去和展位的人交谈时，你就会得到一本宣传册。好吧。我喜欢这个。迈克尔很生气贾斯汀在他们的白纸上签了名。当他得知帕姆只带了一张时，他更生气了。是的，帕姆说，对不起？我喜欢她完全指责他的样子。我知道。她说，迈克尔，你不记得了吗？
I said, are you sure that we only need one sheet of paper? And you said, yeah, we only need one sheet of paper to make a difference. And then you sneezed in my tea and said, don't worry, it's just allergies. Pam, with the receipts. That's what the kids say, Jenna. Oh, I like it. Mm-hmm. We had a fan question from Kate B.
我说，你确定我们只需要一张纸吗？你说，是的，我们只需要一张纸就能有所作为。然后你打了个喷嚏在我的茶里，说，别担心，只是过敏。帕姆，带着证据。这就是孩子们说的，珍娜。哦，我喜欢。嗯哼。我们有一个来自凯特B的粉丝问题。
When Justin signs his name on the piece of paper, he writes Justin E. But later in the episode, he tells Michael that his last name is Pulsnick. Explain. Hmm. I'll tell you. I am intrigued. The actor who plays Justin, his name is Trevor Einhorn. Oh, so maybe he was writing his actual last name.
当贾斯汀在纸上签名时，他写的是贾斯汀·E。但后来在这一集中，他告诉迈克尔他的姓是普尔斯尼克。解释一下。嗯。我告诉你。我很感兴趣。扮演贾斯汀的演员，他的名字叫特雷弗·艾因霍恩。哦，所以也许他写的是他真实的姓氏。
Yes. Isn't that amazing? Mm-hmm. So Trevor Einhorn has been a professional actor since he was five years old, and his breakout role was on the television comedy, Frazier. He played Frederick Crane, the son of Frazier and Lilith. Oh my gosh. Yes. He also went on to have a recurring role on Mad Men.
是的。这不是很神奇吗？嗯哼。所以特雷弗·艾因霍恩从五岁起就是一名职业演员，他的突破性角色是在电视喜剧《欢乐一家亲》中。他扮演了弗雷泽和莉莉丝的儿子弗雷德里克·克莱恩。哦，天哪。是的。他后来还在《广告狂人》中担任常驻角色。
He was in season six and seven as a copywriter. And he also played Neil Kellerman in the ABC remake of Dirty Dancing. Hmm. He currently stars as Josh Hoberman in the sci-fi show The Magicians. He is a Scorpio. I'll have you know. That's new for a guest. I don't feel like you've shared their Zodiac sign before.
他在第六季和第七季中担任文案。他还扮演了ABC翻拍版《辣身舞》中的尼尔·凯勒曼。嗯。他目前在科幻剧《魔法师》中饰演乔什·霍伯曼。他是个天蝎座。我得告诉你。这对嘉宾来说是新的。我觉得你以前没分享过他们的星座。
Is this a new part of the guest star breakdown? Well, it showed up in his bio, so I thought I'd throw it in there. Okay. Finally, he is not related to our cinematographer, Randall Einhorn. That is correct. Just a coincidence. Everyone back in the bullpen still really wants to sneak. out. They've waited for their moment. Dwight finally gets up and exits the bullpen to go to the
这是嘉宾介绍的新部分吗？好吧，它出现在他的简历里，所以我想我把它加进去。好吧。最后，他和我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩没有关系。这是正确的。只是巧合。大家回到办公室仍然非常想溜
bathroom. And Creed calls Angela to tell her they're all leaving. This scene made me laugh so hard, Jenna, because this is a bit that Creed and I still do. To this day, Creed will text me, Pumpkins out. Or if we hang out, I'm like, all right, Creed, I'm going to go. He'll say, Pumpkins out. Like, he still says this to me after all of these years. And this just warmed my heart. I loved it so much. Sam, can you play the clip? Extension 1-28. Hi, your pumpkin. It's Creed. Say we're going to ditch this bitch. You in?
出去。他们一直在等待时机。德怀特终于站起来离开了办公室去
No. Are you out? Pumpkin's out. Let's go, gang. We got so much mail about this scene, Angela. People who listen to the podcast know that Creed calls you pumpkin in real life. And they wanted to know was Creed ad-living in the scene and using his real-life nickname for you? or was pumpkin in the script? And then he started calling you pumpkin after this.
洗手间。克里德打电话给安吉拉告诉她他们都要走了。这个场景让我笑得太厉害了，珍娜，因为这是克里德和我至今仍在做的梗。直到今天，克里德还会给我发短信，南瓜走了。或者如果我们一起出去玩，我说，好吧，克里德，我要走了。他会说，南瓜走了。就像，这么多年过去了，他仍然对我这么说。这真的温暖了我的心。我太喜欢了。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？分机1-28。嗨，你的南瓜。我是克里德。说我们要甩掉这个婊子。你加入吗？
This scene is exactly as it is in the script. Exactly. So Creed did not improvise that, but I will tell you, ever since we shot Job Fair, he has called me pumpkin. To this day, he still calls me pumpkin. That is so cute.
不。你退出了吗？南瓜走了。走吧，伙计们。我们收到了很多关于这个场景的邮件，安吉拉。听播客的人知道克里德在现实生活中叫你南瓜。他们想知道克里德在那个场景中是即兴发挥并用了他现实生活中对你的昵称吗？还是南瓜在剧本里？然后他之后才开始叫你南瓜。
I know. It's so cute. I loved that scene. Well, now Dwight comes out of the restroom and he sees that everyone has left. Everyone except Angela. Mm-hmm.
这个场景和剧本里的一模一样。完全一样。所以克里德没有即兴发挥，但我会告诉你，自从我们拍摄招聘会以来，他就一直叫我南瓜。直到今天，他仍然叫我南瓜。那太可爱了。
Which makes total sense because she's the one other rule follower in this group. Mm-hmm. There is a great scene that's deleted where Dwight comes out and he goes, Ha! Last man standing. And then Angela briskly walks past him and goes, excuse me. And then there's a talking head that Angela has that really explains why she is just as eager to be one of the last people in the office.
我知道。太可爱了。我喜欢那个场景。好吧，现在德怀特从洗手间出来，看到大家都走了。除了安吉拉。嗯哼。
Whenever I'm here by myself, I like to pretend that all the others are dead. So this is nice. I'll laugh out loud. I spit out my water. I went to take a sip of water while we were listening to the deleted scene. It seemed like a safe time to take a sip of water. But that was so good. She pretends that everyone is dead.
这完全说得通，因为她是这群人中另一个遵守规则的人。嗯哼。有一个很棒的删减场景，德怀特出来说，哈！最后一个人。然后安吉拉轻快地从他身边走过说，对不起。然后安吉拉有一个采访镜头，真正解释了为什么她也同样渴望成为办公室里最后离开的人之一。
And at the end, they had me do a little smile, like that I was very delighted by this. Oh, that is incredible. Well, Dwight's going to use this opportunity to call Michael and tattle. He is very, very mad. Michael is like, yeah, that makes total sense. Don't be weird. Everyone should go home. Why should they be there? I'm not there. Jim's not there. Who cares? Right? Dwight is so sad. I know. But Dwight isn't going to go home. He has personal standards. He's going to work his day. And he's going to dock everyone else's pay. He's going to try. Back at the job fair, Pam has gone into her old art room to get a sheet of paper. I titled this scene, brutal.
每当我独自在这里时，我喜欢假装其他人都死了。所以这很好。我大声笑了出来。我把水喷了出来。我们听删减片段时，我想喝口水。这似乎是个喝水的好时机。但这太棒了。她假装所有人都死了。
Pam just wants one moment of her glory days, right? One moment. She's going to show the camera, her piece of art. Surely it's still on the wall. Yeah, we got a lot of mail about this. People wanted to know what exactly is Pam looking for on the wall. Was it artwork? Was it an award? They wanted to know if there was more to this scene. And also just, what was my take on this? I'll tell you, the idea was that when Pam was in school, a piece of her art was put on the wall on display. And it was a big moment for her that she was very proud of. And she very, very quickly, as soon as she says maybe it's still there, realizes that like a decade has gone by since this moment that she was so proud of,
最后，他们让我做了一个小微笑，好像我对这一点感到非常高兴。哦，那太不可思议了。好吧，德怀特要利用这个机会给迈克尔打电话告状。他非常非常生气。迈克尔说，是的，这完全说得通。别奇怪。每个人都应该回家。他们为什么要待在那里？我不在那儿。吉姆也不在那儿。谁在乎呢？对吧？德怀特太难过了。我知道。但德怀特不会回家。他有个人标准。他要完成他的一天。他要扣掉其他所有人的工资。他会尝试的。回到招聘会，帕姆去了她以前的艺术教室拿一张纸。我把这个场景命名为，残酷。
probably the last moment that her art was held up for admiration. Because remember, her art show didn't go great. Right. And so she just has this crushing, like you said, brutal realization that a lot of time has gone by since she invested in this part of herself. And she's quickly embarrassed and it has to just stuff it down and walk away. Well, it is exactly the same in the script as what you see in the episode. Yeah. In the script, it says, Pam comes up to a room that is labeled art room and goes inside and walks confidently to the supply desk.
帕姆只是想要她辉煌岁月的一刻，对吧？一刻。她要向摄像机展示她的艺术作品。肯定还在墙上。是的，我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。人们想知道帕姆到底在墙上找什么。是艺术品吗？是一个奖项吗？他们想知道这个场景是否还有更多内容。还有，我对这个有什么看法？我告诉你，想法是当帕姆在学校时，她的一件艺术品被放在墙上展示。这对她来说是一个非常自豪的重要时刻。而且她非常非常快地，一旦她说也许它还在那里，就意识到距离她如此自豪的这一刻已经过去十年了，
She finds a blank piece of paper and shows it to the camera. Pam says, my old art room, hey, I wonder if it's still here. She looks around at the walls that have some student art works on them. Nope. They must have taken it down. Never mind. Yeah. It's hard.
可能是她的艺术作品最后一次被拿出来供人欣赏。因为记住，她的艺术展进行得并不顺利。对。所以她就像你说的，有一种崩溃的、残酷的认识，即自从她投入这部分自己以来，已经过去了很长时间。她很快感到尴尬，不得不把它压下去走开。好吧，它在剧本里和你在剧集中看到的一模一样。是的。在剧本里，它说，帕姆走到一个标有艺术教室的房间，走进去，自信地走向供应台。
It's hard to realize that you've put your hopes and dreams on hold. Yeah. And she does in this moment. You know, after all that, Pam brings this piece of paper to Michael and it's wrong. He wanted Dunder Mifflin card stock. He doesn't want this stupid, random piece of paper. He sends her back to the office. this. Yeah, he said, I don't want this Pendleton crap, which I looked up online and I couldn't find
很难意识到你已经把自己的希望和梦想搁置了。是的。她在这一刻确实意识到了。你知道，在那之后，帕姆把那张纸拿给迈克尔看，结果拿错了。他想要的是邓德·米夫林公司的卡纸。他才不想要这种愚蠢、随意的纸。他让她回办公室去拿。是的，他说，我不想要这种彭德尔顿的垃圾，我在网上查了一下，没找到
Pendleton paper. I did find Pendleton business cards. But he says, Pam, I want the ultra white cardstock. Pam drives all the way back to under Mifflin. Yeah. And she goes and gets the ultra white cardstock out of the copier. Dwight looks puzzled and rightly so, because I don't think that paper lives in the copier, just going to say. Well, let me tell you something. thing about copiers, Angela. She pulls it from a specialty drawer in the copier, not from the main paper feed of the copier, which could have held copy paper, perhaps in our special drawer. You can select for when you want cartstock. Well, I saw that she pulled it from the low drawer, Jenna. I saw that and not the other drawer, but I just think it would be on the shelf. So, well, if it had been
彭德尔顿纸。我确实找到了彭德尔顿的名片。但他对帕姆说，我想要超白卡纸。帕姆一路开车回邓德·米夫林。是的。她去复印机里拿超白卡纸。德怀特看起来很困惑，这是理所当然的，因为我不认为那种纸是放在复印机里的，我正想说。好吧，安吉拉，让我告诉你关于复印机的一件事。她是从复印机的一个专用抽屉里拿出来的，而不是从复印机的主进纸槽里，主进纸槽里可能放的是复印纸，也许在我们的专用抽屉里。你可以选择什么时候需要卡纸。好吧，珍娜，我看到她是把纸从下面的抽屉里拿出来的。我看到了，不是从另一个抽屉，但我只是觉得它应该在架子上。所以，好吧，如果它在
on the shelf, it wouldn't have been as good of a shot between Dwight and Angela. So it had to come out of the copier, all right? That's the real reason. Okay, fine, fine. Well, we're about to go back to the golf course and there's a lot to talk about. I think maybe we should take a break and then we'll get into it after we've refreshed ourselves and emptied our bladders. I will wash my hands. If you need to know who Jenna's going to be at 70, you just heard her. After we have a refreshed ourselves and emptied our bladders. All right, guys, we'll be right back. All right, we are back.
架子上，就不会有德怀特和安吉拉之间那么好的镜头了。所以它必须从复印机里出来，好吗？这就是真正的原因。好吧，行吧。我们要回高尔夫球场了，有很多事情要谈。我想也许我们应该休息一下，等我们恢复精神并排空膀胱后再继续。我会去洗手。如果你想知道珍娜70岁时会是什么样子，你刚才已经听到了。等我们恢复精神并排空膀胱之后。好了，伙计们，我们马上回来。好了，我们回来了。
Mr. McGuire is struggling with his ball. I like that. He's struggling with his ball in the sand trap. He can't get it out of the sand, Jenna. And he doesn't want anyone to help him. He wants to do it himself. And listen, Andy is just such a hot mess. He's having all of his rage issues.
麦奎尔先生正在和他的球较劲。我喜欢这个。他在沙坑里和他的球较劲。他没法把它从沙子里弄出来，珍娜。而且他不希望任何人帮他。他想自己解决。听着，安迪真是个烂摊子。他所有的愤怒问题都爆发了。
He's got on his pants that have little pheasants on them. It's not going to make him happy when Jim gets a phone call from Pam while Andy's trying to swing. No, it is not. And Jim is really trying to recruit Mr. McGuire. And McGuire is a big no. He's just like, no, no, no. He just wants to play golf. Well, so does Andy, because he proposes that they race to the next hole.
他穿着那条上面有小野鸡图案的裤子。当吉姆在安迪试图挥杆时接到帕姆的电话时，他可不会高兴。不，他不会的。吉姆真的在试图招募麦奎尔先生。而麦奎尔完全拒绝了。他就像，不，不，不。他只想打高尔夫球。好吧，安迪也一样，因为他提议他们比赛看谁先到下一个洞。
He hops in the golf cart and crashes it. He goes flying. The roof of the golf cart is ripped off. This is a major golf cart. crash. I mean, I feel like this was a big stunt for us. It was. We got a lot of mail about it. People wanted to know, did Ed do this stunt? No. No, no, no, no, no. Of course not. No, no, no. It was a stunt driver. We also got questions about everyone's actual golfing ability. Thomas V wants to know, did any of these guys actually play golf? Well, well, well, well, we will tell you.
他跳进高尔夫球车，然后撞车了。他飞了出去。高尔夫球车的车顶被掀掉了。这是一次重大高尔夫球车事故。我的意思是，我觉得这对我们来说是一个很大的特技表演。确实是。我们收到了很多关于它的邮件。人们想知道，这是艾德亲自做的特技吗？不。不，不，不，不。当然不是。不，不，不。那是特技替身。我们还收到了关于每个人实际高尔夫水平的问题。托马斯·V想知道，这些人里真的有人会打高尔夫吗？好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，我们会告诉你们的。
We know. I reached a. out to Ed and he said that before this episode, he had never been a golfer and that the show gave everybody lessons so that they could look like they knew what they were doing. And he really, really enjoyed it. And he said since this episode, he has started playing recreationally. But he added, it's just for fun, nothing like Brian Baumgartner. Brian is an athlete, you guys. We have talked about this before. He's a heck of a golfer. Oh, Ange, he told me that his handicap is Seven. That's really, really good, you guys. That's really good. He plays on these big, fancy golf tournaments, you guys.
我们知道。我联系了艾德，他说在这一集之前，他从来没打过高尔夫，剧组给了每个人课程，这样他们看起来就像知道自己在做什么一样。他真的很享受。他说自从这一集之后，他开始进行娱乐性打球了。但他补充说，这只是为了好玩，不像布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳。布莱恩是个运动员，伙计们。我们之前谈过这个。他是个高尔夫高手。哦，安吉，他告诉我他的差点是7。这真的很棒，伙计们。真的很棒。他参加那些大型、高级的高尔夫锦标赛，伙计们。
Like Michael Jordan has a golf tournament and Brian plays in it. Brian won the Derek Jeter Celebrity Invitational one year. Yeah. He goes to so many professional celebrity golf tournaments. He told me he has a room of suitcases because apparently there was a year where they gifted every golfer a suitcase. Okay. He's like, I have so many suitcases if you ever need a suitcase. That's crazy. Well, Brian also told me that they didn't play any actual golf while shooting these scenes.
就像迈克尔·乔丹有高尔夫锦标赛，布莱恩也会参加。布莱恩曾赢得过一届德里克·基特名人邀请赛。是的。他参加了这么多职业名人高尔夫锦标赛。他告诉我他有一个专门放行李箱的房间，因为显然有一年他们送给每个高尔夫球手一个行李箱。好吧。他说，如果你需要行李箱，我这里有很多。这太疯狂了。好吧，布莱恩还告诉我，他们在拍摄这些场景时并没有真正打高尔夫。
They hit a lot of balls, but they didn't have time to play much actual short game golf, you know? I bet he was bummed because he would have just schooled them all. I think so. And then I texted John. John told me that he absolutely loves playing golf, but he is. horrible. I think he's no better than Jim. But he said that the reason Brian Baumgartner likes to golf with John is because that way Brian can really dominate. Oh, a little, a little shade there at Brian. I guess so. Well, that is why it made sense to me that Kevin went,
他们击了很多球，但没有时间进行太多实际的短杆高尔夫比赛，你知道吗？我打赌他很失望，因为他本可以教训他们所有人。我想也是。然后我给约翰发了短信。约翰告诉我他非常喜欢打高尔夫，但他很糟糕。我觉得他并不比吉姆强。但他说是布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳喜欢和约翰一起打高尔夫的原因，因为这样布莱恩就能真正占据主导地位。哦，对布莱恩有点讽刺。我想是吧。好吧，这就是为什么我觉得凯文去参加是合理的，
because Kevin's not in sales. Kevin's an accountant. But I thought, I wonder if the writers were like, we need one guy that looks like he knows what he's doing. Well, Lee gave an interview after this episode aired because someone had asked that very question, why Kevin? And he said after they picked who would go to the job fair, they had to look at who was left. Because remember, Jim is trying to woo a client. So we learned from this deleted scene that he brought Andy as his way of maybe being able to have this common enemy over the Dartmouth Cornell thing. And he brought Kevin maybe because he was the last best athletic choice in the office.
因为凯文不在销售部。凯文是会计。但我当时想，不知道编剧们是不是在想，我们需要一个看起来知道自己在做什么的人。好吧，李在这一集播出后接受了采访，因为有人问了那个问题，为什么是凯文？他说在他们选出谁去招聘会后，他们不得不看看剩下的人是谁。因为记住，吉姆正在试图争取一个客户。所以我们从这个删减片段中了解到，他带上安迪是因为这可能是他能够就达特茅斯和康奈尔大学的事情找到共同敌人的方式。他带上凯文可能是因为他是办公室里剩下的最后一个运动能力较好的选择。
It works. I also think Kevin provided them with that extra storyline of the betting because that tracks for Kevin's character. Yeah. It's the time he's good at math. Exactly. Well, back at the job fair, literally no one is interested in Dunder Mifflin. So Michael is going to have to revisit this idea of hiring Justin. Oh, and lady, there is a deleted scene that really explains why Michael is like, well, I
这很有效。我也认为凯文为他们提供了关于赌博的额外故事情节，因为这符合凯文的角色。是的。这是他擅长数学的时候。没错。好吧，回到招聘会，真的没有人对邓德·米夫林感兴趣。所以迈克尔不得不重新考虑雇佣贾斯汀的想法。哦，女士，有一个删减片段真的解释了为什么迈克尔会觉得，好吧，我
guess I should reach out to Justin. There's sort of like a young hip, like, student that walks by and Michael chats him up. And the guy is just being nice, right? The kid is being nice. And Michael is just relentless and just wants him to be his best friend, like literally wants him to be his best friend. And the kid's like, okay, you know what? You're starting to creep me out. I was just trying to be nice. I don't want to work at your stupid paper company. And Michael is devastated. And that is when he sort of has this moment of like, oh, crap. Like if Justin's the only one that's interested. Well, Michael brings Justin around and introduces him to everyone.
猜我应该联系贾斯汀。有一个年轻时髦的学生走过，迈克尔和他搭讪。那家伙只是表现得很有礼貌，对吧？那孩子很有礼貌。而迈克尔却不依不饶，只想让他成为自己最好的朋友，简直是想让他成为自己最好的朋友。那孩子说，好吧，你知道吗？你让我觉得毛骨悚然。我只是想表现得友好一点。我不想在你那愚蠢的造纸公司工作。迈克尔崩溃了。就在那时，他产生了一种，哦，该死的感觉。就像如果贾斯汀是唯一感兴趣的人。好吧，迈克尔把贾斯汀带过来并把他介绍给每个人。
But in the process of introducing Pam, he says, she'll do you. I mean, just kidding, but she has dated two guys in the office that we know of. And this leads to one of my favorite lines of the whole series. Is it what Michael says? Yes. Pam walks away. And Michael says to Justin, listen, I wouldn't say this to her face, but she's a wonderful person and a gifted artist. He wouldn't say it to her face. I feel like it's Oscar's delivery of Oscar's line that makes me laugh so hard because he goes,
但在介绍帕姆的过程中，他说，她会和你上床的。我是说，开个玩笑，但据我们所知，她和办公室里的两个男人约会过。这引出了我整个系列中最喜欢的台词之一。是迈克尔说的吗？是的。帕姆走开了。迈克尔对贾斯汀说，听着，我不会当着她的面说，但她是一个很棒的人，也是一位有天赋的艺术家。他不会当着她的面说。我觉得是奥斯卡说这句台词的方式让我笑得这么厉害，因为他说，
why wouldn't you say that to her face? I know. I love that couplet. That joke is so funny to me. So you guys, not only has Michael been, you know, in deleted scenes, ditched by the hip, cool kid, right? he then sees Justin being chatted up by the Air Force recruiter. And in a deleted scene, Michael walks over. And the Air Force recruiter is telling Justin how amazing he is, what a great asset he would be.
你为什么不当着她的面说呢？我知道。我喜欢那句对白。那个笑话对我来说太搞笑了。所以伙计们，迈克尔不仅在删减片段中被那个时髦、酷酷的孩子甩了，对吧？他随后看到贾斯汀正在和空军招聘人员聊天。在一个删减片段中，迈克尔走了过去。空军招聘人员正在告诉贾斯汀他有多棒，他会成为多么宝贵的资产。
And Michael is like, no, no, no, no, no, you need to work for us. He like gets really sort of aggressive and offers Justin this job. And that part makes it into the episode where Justin declines. But there's a whole other scene where the Air Force is really going after Justin. Wow. Justin's two choices are the Air Force or Dunder Mifflin paper. Those are real different sides of the pendulum there. Very different. And Michael says to the Air Force recruiter, you're telling me this guy could be a fighter pilot? He's like, yes, he can. And Michael's like, ugh. My God. Well, a woman comes to the microphone and announces that the job fair is coming to an end. Yes. And that woman, was played by our female stand-in Lori Sox. Yes, if you go to 15 minutes, 58 seconds, you will see Lori. We loved Lori and her husband, Stephen, their husband and wife, stand-in duo.
迈克尔说，不，不，不，不，不，你需要为我们工作。他变得有点咄咄逼人，并向贾斯汀提供了这份工作。那部分进入了正片，贾斯汀拒绝了。但还有另一整段场景是空军真的在争取贾斯汀。哇。贾斯汀的两个选择是空军或邓德·米夫林纸业。那是钟摆的两端，非常不同。非常不同。迈克尔对空军招聘人员说，你是说这家伙可以成为战斗机飞行员？他说，是的，他可以。迈克尔说，呃。天哪。好吧，一位女士走到麦克风前宣布招聘会即将结束。是的。那位女士是由我们的女性替身洛里·索克斯扮演的。是的，如果你看到15分58秒，你就会看到洛里。我们爱洛里和她的丈夫斯蒂芬，他们是夫妻替身组合。
They were with us for years. They were like family. Well, you might remember Stephen because he was featured at the dinner table in Benihana Christmas. Yes. And so from time to time, they pop up in episodes. And like Angela said, these guys really are like family to us. Stephen and Lori have two kids. And Lori had Sophia before I had Isabel.
他们和我们在一起多年。他们就像家人一样。好吧，你可能记得斯蒂芬，因为他在《班尼汉纳圣诞节》的餐桌上出现过。是的。所以他们不时会在剧集中出现。就像安吉拉说的，这些人对我们来说真的就像家人一样。斯蒂芬和洛里有两个孩子。洛里生索菲亚的时候，我还没生伊莎贝尔。
And Jenna, she was my person. I went to. I'd be like, Lori, I'm feeling this or I'm doing this. Or I had a question about breastfeeding. And she was just always there to sort of guide me through being a working mom. It was Lori and Malora. They were the two moms I went to. Yes.
珍娜，她就是我的依靠。我去找她。我会说，洛里，我有这种感觉，或者我正在做这个。或者我有关于母乳喂养的问题。她总是会在那里引导我如何成为一名职场妈妈。是洛里和马洛拉。她们是我求助的两位妈妈。是的。
Yeah. Both of her kids were born while we shot the office. Mm-hmm. So her daughter, Sophia, is 13. I know her and Isabel are very close in age. And their son Liam, who just turned 10 years old. I can't believe he's 10. I know.
是的。她的两个孩子都是在我们拍摄《办公室》期间出生的。嗯哼。所以她的女儿索菲亚13岁了。我知道她和伊莎贝尔年龄很接近。还有他们的儿子利亚姆，刚满10岁。我不敢相信他10岁了。我知道。
Passage of time. You see it in your children. Well, their son Liam has Down syndrome. And Stephen and Lori actually have this amazing podcast, and we want to shout it out. It's called If We New Then. And it is a Down syndrome advocacy podcast for parents. Their goal is to reach as many parents and prospective parents as possible. The podcast features interviews and positive information about Down syndrome advocacy and
时光流逝。你在你的孩子身上看到了这一点。好吧，他们的儿子利亚姆患有唐氏综合症。斯蒂芬和洛里实际上有一个很棒的播客，我们想大声宣传一下。它叫《如果当时我们知道》。这是一个为父母提供的唐氏综合症倡导播客。他们的目标是尽可能多地接触到父母和准父母。该播客以采访和关于唐氏综合症倡导和
inclusion. You guys definitely check it out. Check it out. Again, it's called If We New Then. It is so good. I just listened to their episode where they talk about the week that they had Liam in the hospital and everything they were journeying through in that moment. And they are so kind, relatable, thoughtful, caring people. I really enjoyed their conversation. We're just so happy to share about their podcast. We're going to put them in our stories. We'll put a swipe up to your podcast, guys. And Lori and Stephen, we just love you guys so much.
包容性的积极信息为特色。你们一定要去听听。去看看吧。再说一次，它叫《如果当时我们知道》。它太棒了。我刚听了他们谈论利亚姆在医院的那一周以及他们当时经历的一切的那一集。他们是非常善良、容易产生共鸣、体贴、关心他人的人。我真的很喜欢他们的谈话。我们很高兴分享他们的播客。我们会把他们放到我们的故事里。我们会放一个向上滑动的链接到你们的播客，伙计们。洛里和斯蒂芬，我们真的很爱你们。
It is so fun for me to see them pop up in these episodes. We saw them every day at work. So we're excited that they've been memorialized in the episode for everybody. Yes. And Stephen is still part of that very competitive fantasy football league of the office cast and crew. Yes, Lee told me that actually Stephen is responsible for the draft pick numbers every year. And there is a tradition where he makes a video of Sophia and Liam
看到他们出现在这些剧集中对我来说太有趣了。我们每天在工作中都能见到他们。所以我们很高兴他们被记录在剧集中供大家观看。是的。而且斯蒂芬仍然是那个竞争激烈的《办公室》演职人员梦幻足球联盟的一员。是的，李告诉我，实际上斯蒂芬每年负责选秀号码。有一个传统，他会制作一个索菲亚和利亚姆的视频，
reaching into a bowl and picking out the numbers for the order of the draft. That's how all these guys find out their pick number is from Sophia and Liam every year. I love our office family. I love it. Well, you guys, Michael's getting desperate and he's going to do that classic thing that Michael does where he has to go up on stage and take the microphone. Yeah. He wants to know if anyone wants to intern at Dunder Mifflin. He says they do not offer college credit and they cannot give you any sort of pay, but it's a super fun work environment. Anyone? Show of hands. Anyone? Yeah. It's amazing. I mean, security comes pretty quickly. Yes, I know, with Lori, like marching right in front. Yeah, it's not going to go great. They're going to leave with no interns. They're going to leave with no interns and no one
伸手进碗里挑选选秀顺序的号码。这就是这些人每年从索菲亚和利亚姆那里得知他们选秀号码的方式。我爱我们的办公室大家庭。我爱它。好吧，伙计们，迈克尔变得绝望了，他要做那种迈克尔式的经典动作，他必须走上舞台拿过麦克风。是的。他想知道是否有人想在邓德·米夫林实习。他说他们不提供大学学分，也不能给任何报酬，但这是一个超级有趣的工作环境。有人吗？举手示意。有人吗？是的。这太神奇了。我的意思是，保安很快就来了。是的，我知道，洛里就像直接走在前面一样。是的，这不会有什么好结果。他们会带着没有实习生的结果离开。他们会带着没有实习生离开，而且没有人
ever wanting to work there. Thanks, Michael. Speaking of Dundermifflin and working there, We should probably catch you up on how it's going between little Dwight and Angela back at the office. First, they had to make some copies. I took a screen grab of this scene of us making copies. It really perfectly shows how much they had to crop me out. Oh, yeah, your shoulders up. I know. Can I say something that I noticed about this scene?
想在那里工作。谢谢你，迈克尔。说到邓德·米夫林和在那里工作，我们可能应该让你们了解一下小德怀特和安吉拉在办公室里的进展。首先，他们得复印一些东西。我截取了我们复印场景的屏幕截图。它非常完美地展示了他们必须把我剪掉多少。哦，是的，你的肩膀以上。我知道。我能说一件我注意到这个场景的事情吗？
Okay. There's only two people in the office. Apparently you need to make copies at the same time. So there's a line. Mm-hmm. There's also a copier in the annex. I think Angela just wanted to stand close to him. I think she did too. I think her heart is melting a little. You know, it's taken her a bit. He did freeze her cat. So she's had a lot to unpack there. But I think she's softening. Well, Dwight's going to sneeze and Angela's going to say, bless you. I know. I think it's the beginning, the beginning of the Angela and Dwight rekindling. And I have more evidence if you needed more. What? As they're leaving for the day, Dwight holds the door.
好吧。办公室里只有两个人。显然你们需要同时复印。所以排队了。嗯哼。附楼里也有复印机。我想安吉拉只是想站在他身边。我想她也是。我想她的心有点融化了。你知道，这花了一点时间。他确实冷冻了她的猫。所以她有很多事情要处理。但我认为她正在软化。好吧，德怀特要打喷嚏了，安吉拉要说，保佑你。我知道。我认为这是安吉拉和德怀特重燃爱火的开始。如果你需要更多证据，我还有。什么？当他们下班离开时，德怀特扶着门。
He waits and holds the door for Angela. And she says, thank you. I know. I mean, this is in their language like this is on again almost. Oh, yeah. They're about to go to the warehouse and hook up. Right. Exactly.
他等着并为安吉拉扶着门。她说，谢谢。我知道。我的意思是，这在他们的语言里就像是几乎又要在一起了。哦，是的。他们正要回仓库去亲热。对。没错。
Exactly. That's about to happen. Well, back at the golf course, turns out Kevin did okay. He wants to collect his money from all of his winnings. But Mr. McGuire says, no, no, no, we'll start a tab because I'm going to play more golf with you guys. Hmm. He'll play more golf with them, but he refuses still to give Jim his business. But Jim isn't going to take no for an answer.
没错。这就要发生了。好吧，回到高尔夫球场，事实证明凯文做得不错。他想从他所有的赢利中收钱。但麦奎尔先生说，不，不，不，我们先记账，因为我还要和你们一起打更多高尔夫。嗯。他会和他们打更多高尔夫，但他仍然拒绝把生意交给吉姆。但吉姆不会接受拒绝。
No, he's going to throw himself in front of this man's car. Yeah, I found it a little off-putting. Jim said he said he would call him. him every day until he gave him his business. Well, it works on Mr. McGuire. I feel like Jim is using Dwight's sales tactics. He's certainly exercising persistence, and I guess it pays off. Mr. McGuire says, okay, there you go. It worked. And they're going to come back to the office, and they're going to be drinking some beers, toasting their good fortune, as Michael and Pam and Oscar and Darry. return from the job fair.
不，他要冲到这个人的车前。是的，我觉得这有点让人反感。吉姆说他会每天给他打电话，直到他把生意交给他。好吧，这对麦奎尔先生有效。我觉得吉姆在用德怀特的销售策略。他确实在行使坚持不懈的精神，我想这得到了回报。麦奎尔先生说，好吧，给你。它奏效了。他们要回到办公室，他们要喝些啤酒，为他们的好运干杯，当迈克尔、帕姆、奥斯卡和达里尔从招聘会回来时。
And Pam is like, you did it. You closed the deal. You sold it. And she runs up. And they smooch. Then they shake hands because they're like awkward. And then they completely make out in front of everyone. Angela, I remember shooting this scene.
帕姆说，你做到了。你完成了交易。你把它卖出去了。她跑了过来。他们亲吻了。然后他们握手，因为他们觉得很尴尬。然后他们在所有人面前完全吻了起来。安吉拉，我记得拍摄这个场景。
PDA, awkward. We were kissing for so long. It felt like a long time. And it's not even hardly on camera. Now that I see the episode. You're like, wait a second. But part of this big kiss was because we had this shorter season from the writer's strike. And we didn't get to advance a lot of jammy storylines after all, right?
公开秀恩爱，尴尬。我们吻了太久了。感觉时间很长。而且在镜头里几乎都没怎么拍到。现在我看到这一集了。你会想，等一下。但这个大吻的一部分是因为我们在编剧罢工后有一个较短的赛季。我们没能推进很多吉姆和帕姆的故事情节，对吧？
They had this whole plan that they were going to move in together. So we're near the end of the season and we had to throw in big jam moment. Right. So here it is. You're going to get to see them have a big smooch. This is, I think, the biggest smooch of the series. really it's the longest smooch I would say the biggest most epic smooch was casino night that was not as long as this well that's what I was about to say I feel like it was a big pivotal smooch but this is the longest smooch
他们有一个完整的计划，他们要搬到一起住。所以我们接近赛季末了，我们不得不加入一个大的吉姆和帕姆时刻。对。所以就是这样。你们会看到他们有一个大吻。我认为这是该系列中最大的吻。真的，这是最长的吻。我会说最大、最史诗般的吻是赌场之夜，那没有这个长。好吧，我正要说，我觉得那是一个重大的关键之吻，但这确实是最长的吻。
yeah and it was very very funny Angela this is my question was it in the script for Michael to say kiss or kiss or good because I could not get through that we were like laughing so hard and my memory is that Steve did that as an improvisation. It's in the script. Oh my gosh. It's in the script. It says Michael has gotten very close to Jim and Pam and is watching them kiss from really far too close.
是的，那真的非常非常搞笑。Angela，这是我的问题：剧本里有写让Michael说“亲她，亲她好一点”吗？因为我当时根本演不下去，我们笑得太厉害了。我的记忆是Steve那是即兴发挥的。剧本里有写。天哪，剧本里真的有。上面写着Michael已经和Jim、Pam走得很近，正从很远的地方看着他们接吻，靠得太近了。
And Michael says, yeah, kiss her. Kiss her good. It was very, very funny. And you can see when John and I separate that my face is a little red. It's a little chaste from so much kiss. We had to do the scene so many times. And you can see. I think John had a little stubble.
然后Michael说：“对，亲她。亲她好一点。”那真的非常非常搞笑。你可以看到当John和我分开时，我的脸有点红。因为亲了太多次，脸都磨红了。我们不得不拍了很多次那个场景。而且你可以看到，我觉得John当时还有点胡茬。
A little stubble. Well, do you want to hear what was in the script? Yeah. Angela and Dwight were there for this moment. What? Yes. And while the guys are drinking beers, Angela shushes them. And then Angela and Dwight have their moment later in the script when they leave and Dwight
一点胡茬。好吧，你想听听剧本里原本写了什么吗？想。Angela和Dwight当时也在那个时刻。什么？是的。当男人们在喝啤酒时，Angela嘘了他们。然后Angela和Dwight在剧本后面有他们的时刻，当他们离开时，Dwight
holds open the door and all that. But how awkward would it have been for Dwight and Angela to be there too? I'm glad they changed that. Yeah, that was a good move. Yeah, you don't need more Angela judgment. Pam doesn't need more. The last scene of this episode is a flashback. Back to the Job Fair.
帮她开门之类的。但如果Dwight和Angela也在那里，那该有多尴尬啊？我很高兴他们改了。是的，那是个好主意。没错，不需要更多的Angela式评判了。Pam不需要更多了。这一集的最后一个场景是闪回，回到招聘会。
This is going to set us up for Pam's storyline in season five. We're going to plant some seeds here. You see Pam go up to a booth for a graphic design firm, and she wants to fill out an application. Yes, and you guys might notice that the graphic design guy is played by Nelson Franklin. He's going to come back in season six as the IT guy. I have a little fun tidbit about Nelson. I know what it is. Tell us. Nelson and I were co-stars on a new show for Netflix, hashtag Black AF. We played writers in the writers room with Kenya Barras and Rashida Jones
这为Pam在第五季的故事线做了铺垫。我们要在这里埋下一些种子。你看到Pam走到一个平面设计公司的展位前，她想填一份申请表。是的，你们可能会注意到那个平面设计男是由Nelson Franklin扮演的。他会在第六季回来扮演IT男。关于Nelson我有一个有趣的小花絮。我知道是什么。告诉我们吧。Nelson和我曾是Netflix新剧《#BlackAF》的联合主演。我们和Kenya Barras以及Rashida Jones一起在编剧室里扮演编剧。
plays Kenya's wife, Joya, and Ken Quapas directed us. It was like a whole office reunion. That show is so funny. Your writer's room scenes are so funny. Angela, your character is amazing in that show. I play yet another miserable woman. You're so good at it. Oh, thanks. I loved all the writer's room bits, you know,
她扮演Kenya的妻子Joya，Ken Quapas执导了我们。那就像是一场办公室重聚。那部剧太搞笑了。你们编剧室的场景太搞笑了。Angela，你的角色在那部剧里太棒了。我又演了一个悲惨的女人。你演得太好了。哦，谢谢。我喜欢所有编剧室的片段，你知道，
because you and I, we've observed writers' rooms over the years, and it was really fun to kind of play out some of that schick. Well, Nelson is amazing. He also had a regular recurring role on VEP. He had a regular role on Blackish. And it's true. He's going to come back in season six. And I don't know how they did that. I'm going to figure it out. When we get to season six, I'm going to tell you it's a little bit of a bewitched moment, isn't it? It is. It's like which Darren is this? I will point out one thing. Nelson joins our very tall male cast member club. He is six foot five. Every scene I have to be in with him, he has to be seated. Well, he's really good in this scene with Pam. You know, he kind of explains to her, you just need like, basic knowledge of all of these programs that Pam has no knowledge of at all. And then he says, you know, you could probably get training somewhere, do like an adult education class, but the best
因为你和我，我们多年来观察过编剧室，能演出来那些桥段真的很有趣。嗯，Nelson太棒了。他还在《副总统》里有常驻角色。他在《黑人一家亲》里也有常驻角色。这是真的。他会在第六季回来。我不知道他们是怎么做到的。我会弄清楚的。当我们到第六季时，我会告诉你们，这有点像《神仙家庭》的时刻，不是吗？确实。就像是“这是哪一个Darren？”。我要指出一点。Nelson加入了我们非常高的男演员俱乐部。他有六英尺五英寸高。我和他演的每一场戏，他都必须坐着。嗯，他在这一场和Pam的戏里演得非常好。你知道，他向她解释说，你只需要对Pam完全不懂的这些程序有基本的了解。然后他说，你知道，你可能可以在某个地方接受培训，上个成人教育班，但最好的
place to go, and this is where we plant the seeds for next season, the best place to learn about graphic design are programs in New York or Philadelphia. And she's like, got it, New York or Philadelphia. Yep. What is Pam going to do? We'll find out. We will. And that was job fair. And lady, I can't believe I'm saying this, but up next is the finale of season four. I know. Already. Thank you guys
去处——这就是我们为下一季埋下种子的地方——学习平面设计的最好地方是纽约或费城的项目。她说：“明白了，纽约或费城。”没错。Pam会怎么做？我们会知道的。我们会知道的。这就是招聘会。天哪，我不敢相信我在说这个，但接下来是第四季的大结局。我知道。这么快。谢谢你们
so much for sending in your questions and comments. Thanks so much to our cast members for letting us bug them about golf and pumpkin out and everything else we hit them up for. Yeah, they're amazing. They are the best. And Lori and Stephen Sox, we love you guys. We'll be putting a swipe up to their podcast if we knew then.
发来问题和评论。非常感谢我们的演员们让我们为了高尔夫、南瓜头和其他所有事情去烦他们。是的，他们太棒了。他们是最好的。还有Lori和Stephen Sox，我们爱你们。如果我们知道的话，我们会放上他们播客的链接。
See you next week. guys. Have a fantastic week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周见，伙计们。祝你们度过愉快的一周。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Juerkins，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是Molly Nugent。Odyssey的执行制片人是Leah Reese Dennis。《办公室女士》由Bill Schultz混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。